I want to let you know about some new
tour dates I will be coming to Miami
Florida or Hollywood Florida actually on
April 7th that is the day before the UFC
fights at the Hard Rock Live
uh we will be in Uncasville Connecticut
on July 21 at the Mohegan Sun Arena
uh we will be in Bethlehem PA on July 22
at the Wind Creek Event Center
and Atlantic City New Jersey July 23rd
at the Hard Rock Live we also have some
tickets left in Houston Texas Hampton
Beach New Hampshire Medford
Massachusetts New York City and Las
Vegas so you can grab those some of
those are bigger venues uh but we will
have screens in those venues
um and that's not going to become the
regular deal
these dates will be live with artist
code Rat King on Wednesday March 1st at
10 A.M local General on sale begins
Friday March 3rd get all your tickets
through theovan.com
t-o-u-r to make sure you're getting
accurately priced uh tickets and thank
you guys so much for your support on the
return of the Rat tour
we now have be good to yourself
crewnecks available in light blue maroon
and cement that embankment gang color
you know it check these out along with
the new windbreaker at
theovinstore.com and thank you for your
support
today's guest just finished his new
album College Park
which you can grab out there uh he has
seven albums that have been created he's
a rapper and a producer he's now delving
more into the worlds of uh YouTube and
tick tocks you can get to know him as a
human
as well uh he's Grammy nominated you may
know him as a young Sinatra today's
guest is logic
[Music]
[Applause]
that elevator that's annoying I have a
[__] elevator in my like house well
it's like on the outside of it dang Rich
chat but wow bro what do you mean you
have a real elevator and what do you
have people like waiting like how do you
well no there's just an elevator that's
like it's like in my building
but it's basically my elevator basically
like so say if you get in it and the
doors open where are you
I'm right I'm at my door but are you in
your apartment in your condo or home or
are you at no I'm like a doorway okay
but it's not a Lobby it's like a private
it's like right there like it's like a
shared it's like me and the other
because I'm in Malibu in this condo so
oh nice it's a Vibe so you go all the
way down but wait what I was gonna say
was
I'm really happy to be here thanks man
seriously you're like Tick Tock Ellen oh
damn it's a big deal to be here that's
cool I didn't know that I mean we have a
similar haircut or at some point we did
and we're both from Louisiana
um
which is kind of crazy you probably
wouldn't think that Ellen's from
Louisiana huh I didn't know that you
were both I didn't know she was from
there yeah I think she grew up there can
you look that up Zach
huh Ellen Ellen DeGeneres
yo Ellen DeGeneres is that was my big
thing I always wanted to be on Ellen
because I watched Ellen since I was a
little boy yeah then I was like yo if
you make it on Ellen like you made it
and then I actually went to Ellen and
performed I met Kobe he was there when
you went on dude yeah Kobe was there
let's see what does it say Metairie
Louisiana wow Louisiana that's crazy wow
metairie's kind of wild Metairie is a
good place to uh like if you wanna
um
do drugs with somebody that's Italian
at night okay
well speaking of drugs that's a good
place she she was originally supposed to
be uh
the chicken Pulp Fiction the uh not not
a
Uma Thurman not Uma Thurman's character
but do you remember when Uma when they
were like stabbing her in the heart to
give her the adrenaline the shot of
adrenaline and um the chick's house when
John Travolta was like who's that girl
with all that [__] on her face and he's
like that's my wife Ellen was supposed
to play the chick with all the [__] on
her face oh really yeah fun [__] fact
oh there it is yeah that would have been
Ellen DeGeneres that would have been
Alan yeah oh dang yeah but that was a
highlight for me is when you went there
what'd you mean you went to Ellen yeah I
went there well I went twice actually
damn yeah and then we became like homies
and then next thing I know I'm like us
and our wives are like at her restaurant
and [__] Leonardo DiCaprio comes up
and he's like oh what's up logic blah
blah I'm like what the [__] is going on
what's my life I felt like somehow I was
like joining the Illuminati yeah it was
wild yeah it must sort of feel like as
you get more popular that you start to
meet certain people and you're like damn
am I getting closer to like meeting like
the final like lizard boss or whatever
yeah I guess you know bro it's insane
I'm actually because I'm going ham on
social media now like I'm I'm like
taking it so seriously spending really
good money on you know my my team my
camera guys my editing like I have
in-house editors and I have two houses
that I'm paying because I have so much
[__] that's coming because I really like
editor trafficking it sounds like almost
I'm editor trafficking yeah but it's all
good yeah and no but I really believe in
like this next chapter of my career
where I'm just gonna be making music and
having a blast but like I I feel that
my personality is really what makes me
me and it's what makes logic logic you
know the biracial guy like just being
myself and um
I'm about to lean into that [__] hard as
[__] so but was I saying about Ellen
well it's interesting I think like as I
watch you I think like first obviously
people get to know you through your
music right yeah for sure a lot of
people have but I also then I also find
and I found this I haven't found this
about a lot of musicians and um a lot of
musicians kind of aren't interesting
they're interesting through their music
but they aren't uh I've found a lot of
musicians are tough to interview because
um what's the personification they're
they're trying to portray like who they
are on the record rather than allowing
themselves to just be be them you know
what I mean it's like Mariah Carey takes
shits you know what I mean but maybe she
doesn't want to talk about that you know
what I mean like I got I gotta use wet
wipes what about you
I'm still I'm still afraid to admit
which way I wipe what you mean
you'd be wiping towards the ball I mean
I don't know are you [__] serious
what that's great you what you wipe
towards your balls I don't think so
anyway man so I use
um
I use I use wet wipes I don't know I
mean they should have people like kind
of like that should be something you
have to like instead of like your gender
like say which way you wipe like that
way people can just assume your gender
right there I get it I guess I don't
know but I never heard about I've never
heard of a man wiping towards his balls
yeah that's insane I think that V who
would do it you know nobody I know yeah
anyway question uh I have a question for
you is uh first of all are you cool
talking about like fam nothing weird I'm
just saying like family like if I asked
you about families yeah okay cool
because I don't know you never know yeah
so your dad when he had you was 70 years
old yeah bro
because I was looking [__] up because
like I've seen you know cool stand up
fun stuff like that but I like before I
came to the show I was like man I really
want to know even more about this this
guy
so that means that your father was born
like over 110 years ago yeah let me
think I was just a so funny asses man I
was just thinking about him the other
day and I was thinking about how
um how old he would be if he was alive
he would be he was born in 1910 crazy so
he would be 113.
this year wow that's it'd be crazy my
grandfather was born in 1880.
but to be busting nuts at 70. oh I
didn't want to do it that's wild because
your heart could stop
[Laughter]
that reminds me of my dad like every
time you're like getting close it's just
a risk man
um how old was your dad and thank you
for asking man it's sweet to you that
you that you checked out and you care
it's nice to think about my dad I was
thinking the other day how it would be
cool if they had a place where you could
take clothing from like a deceased
parent and put it on a mannequin and go
spend time with your family in a weird
way that's funny like if people need
that kind of healing in their lives or
something
um I know you had kind of a wild
upbringing so you started out in
Maryland right yes sir okay just for an
audience that doesn't know because some
of our audience might not know you and I
want him to get to know you and so he
started out in Maryland and um and your
parents are met both your parents are
different colors right yeah my dad's
black and my mom is white and I was
conceived in a crack house after they
had met each other after about three
days
yeah
my mom was a prostitute my dad uh was a
crack addict for a long time I'm named
after my dad
and yeah what's really crazy though is I
remember my dad telling me he was like
yeah you know I got a paternity just to
make sure your ass was mine because I
came out looking white as [__] yeah
because it's very apparent my father is
a black man like he's not half black and
that does he's [__] black and
um I thought he did it like when I came
out the canal but the uh literally bro
like three days ago a buddy of mine was
at my crib and he's like oh [__] I got a
warrant I'm like what do you mean you
got a warrant
and he's like I got a warrant Maryland
and I'm like bro when's the last time
you were there he was like 10 years ago
I'm like oh [__] what do you got to do
so he has to write the judge long story
short he was looking up his criminal
history on this website and he's like
yeah you can type in anybody's name and
I'm like yo type in my [__] death so
he types in he types in my dab
and my dad's like bro he like stole my
identity and maxed out credit cards
before I was 18 and [__] because we have
the same name
and so
um
I'm like let's look it up so we look it
up and I'm just seeing like petty theft
car theft possession charges and then I
see Terry Lee Miller my mother's maiden
name
versus Robert Hall defend it and I'm
like what the [__] is this and it says
paternity slash child support bro
it's like 1999 so I'm nine years old
right and I look this it's so crazy like
bro I never knew like you know I heard
about it I kind of saw things when I was
a kid but you don't really put too much
together yeah and then you see on the
internet you're kind of it's almost
you're like wandering through yourself
it's like I'm reading I already wrote a
biography you know what I mean I wrote I
wrote autobiography so now I'm reading
something that's even crazier
and so what's hilarious is that it shows
like that my dad took a paternity test
because he was like that ain't my baby
nine years later and it's nine years
wondering what you if you did something
at eight years old that he's like nah
yeah but the best part is
[__] the internet I'm black I told you I
[__] told you yeah yeah that was wild
dude yeah I think these days yeah being
black definitely helps I think
everything's kind of heading towards
that kind of Ben Simmons kind of trans
sort of vibe where everybody's gonna be
I think honest people that's what I said
we've always said like beige power like
in three generations you can't you're
gonna need it even now you need like a
chart to be racist I feel like you need
like a you know what I'm saying you need
to like carry the one if you're really
gonna get into it you can't even yell
used to just be a little yell like
or something out of the window and it
would land on somebody but now it's like
everybody's yeah yeah exactly um but
yeah crazy that's crazy man did it make
you feel like he didn't care or
something at that point because that
would be I feel like if I saw that or
did your mom like instigate it and so
that's why he had to do it no I think
well I definitely think she wanted child
support but also I'm just like woman
what you gonna get from a crackhead like
I'm just being real right I love my dad
he's clean nowadays I actually I haven't
talked to him in a couple years and I
just texted him the other day and uh so
I'm always trying it's like a [__]
black hole no pun intended that I'm
always trying to go through it's just
whatever anyway I'm like woman
why would you even try to get child
support when the man can't take care of
himself at the time so I'm like it just
to me it doesn't make sense but now your
your dad has my dad on age nut busting
but my dad was 63. this is what's really
great so I'm one of nine wow but I'm the
only child between my mother and my
father so my mother has all all her
children are with black men
and all my brothers and sisters on my
dad's side they're all so everybody's
mixed but I'm the whitest looking I'm
the most transparent
and um
what's crazy is is at 33 years ago after
I was born my dad got a vasectomy okay
and then five years ago I find out that
I have a little brother no
so the story is a wild one now so he was
already chopped out and then he got a
new baby somehow yes that [__] just
poked through and it's his because you
know they made him get a paternity
so would see Brothers has a stack of
pizza man it was wild though about my
dad is that who I love I'm just keeping
it real you know so I always find really
funny is like sometimes my family would
be like we don't want our business out
there and I'm like
well then you shouldn't have done all
that dumb ass [__] what the [__] do you
mean but anyway I would never say
anything too crazy but this is all
public [__] knowledge so either way
yeah exactly so
um my dad I find out I have a little
brother it's like 2018. and um I wrote
about this in my book because I actually
wanted to adopt my brother but that's
another story so wow I had a a
stepmother her name was um Debbie and
Debbie and my dad would use together and
um
Debbie
OD'd and wound up in a coma for four
months so she's in a coma beautiful
woman she's in a coma my dad is like all
right well this sucks he's in the
program AA and he goes up uh to one of
his friends and they're talking to God
they find out that a close friend of his
is dying
um I think it was like cancer or
something so he goes to see her and like
her last words are like take care of my
daughter and her daughter was like this
young 21 year old girl he took care of
her he [__] her and knocked her up no
yeah oh that's true yeah she is so AAA
everyone's [__] each other and it's
knocks her up
shortly after the baby's born she dies
of a heroin overdose
then
um and now this had happened a bit
before but while all this was happening
my dad had
um started seeing a woman who I think is
now his current wife
and then
his then wife comes out of the coma and
he's like
it's over just like yo that's so crazy
well sometimes women take a long time to
make to decide yeah like that's crazy
yeah but it's like wow she can have a
lot of first things she gets out I know
and then of course unfortunately she she
OD'd and died a couple years later but
this is like the life I grew up in man
just drugs and violence and guns and my
brother's running in the streets and you
have surprise siblings it's like
surprise siblings bro like 11 years old
I found out I had four siblings I was
like what it seems like so like such a
chaotic environment to grow up in like
were there times were there like some
special times you remember like spending
with your mom or dad that was just kind
of like you and them one-on-one that
were like that was kind of like a warm
like human kind of time yeah I remember
this one time my dad stole my earring
upon it for crack that was dope damn it
was just one earring too it was just one
earring yeah um no my um I guess
I guess a few times I had with my dad
was music because he's a musician so he
plays like gogo music which is uh you
know prominent in DC and he played with
EU and Chuck Brown and different people
um and I think that's where I get a lot
of my musical talent but he's the type
of [__] though he would like
take me to the studio and if there was
like studio time that he schemed
like I I would get none of it like he'd
be like in there singing like you know
he's got some he's got some songs one of
his most famous lines as a she's just a
crackhead [__] sucking on the devil's
ding dong and he's talking about smoking
a pipe I'm like I feel like that's
copyright dude I've heard that every
crackhead I feel like plays that
straight up I feel like that is like a
national anthem my mom my mom we we
there was definitely for as as sick
mentally as my mother was and is I
haven't talked to her in over a decade
now unfortunately wow um and I'd love to
but she's just not there she's the type
of person to be like don't take the late
lord's name in vain God damn it you
[__] like crazy you know what
I'm saying and she was she would she'd
hit me with the hard R and all my my
brothers and sisters growing up it's
weird it was like yeah man your mom
would imbalm you yeah bro it was like
this systemic because she's you know I
remember her telling me that she brought
you know 14 year old black boy home to
introduce to her parents and they were
like we don't mix with their con here
like wild [__] right it was like old
school racism yeah so it was inner
because she would always obviously she's
[__] black guys like you're not you
know what I mean it's like you know
who's [__] I'm usually back in the
day they were driving like a Honda Civic
it would be kind of like a thick girl
that got sunburned pretty easy and was
driving a Honda Civic and if she was a
redhead dude she's smashing brother
no cat brother was no every girl that
drove by with a in a [__] Honda Civic
dude that was a little bit thick bro I
was catching some sun and freckles were
showing up on her shoulders bro oh my
God she was going over to him I had some
good times I did I had some good times
with my mom but I had more
where like my mother she almost
strangled me to death one time I just
been I've been kidnapped I've been
through the the gnarly as [__] [__]
molested wild [__] but well and that was
just that was my dad's girlfriend she
just kissed me with Skittles in her
[__] mouth and I could taste the
rainbow oh that would make me [__]
hard right
yeah it was great I swear to god dude if
a woman I remember if any woman came
even near me when I was a child I'd get
it wrecked what is up with that though
that's a real thing I used to be in
ninth grade like I couldn't get up
they'd be like could you please write
this mathematical equation and I'm like
I'm [__] doing math exact
Galifianakis to decrease my boner before
you stand up but
yeah I think well for me I think there
was no like I had such a like a rocky
connection with my own mother like she
didn't show me like a lot of and I say
this a lot but I don't really go into it
she like
didn't show me like a lot of affection
and she like would kind of look at me
with judgment all the time and so I
never knew
anytime I got around a woman it was
always like a lot of like real like
uncomfortable energy was this even when
you were like a child did you feel this
way or was it more in your teenage in
later years I didn't notice it until I
got a little bit now I notice it all it
all makes a lot of sense yeah but yeah I
think my mother would just always had a
lot of she never looked at me like just
with like adoration there was always
like judgment and so I think I always
interpreted that like with a woman that
there's always some type of judgment so
I'm not enough immediately when I show
up or even look at a woman it's like
even when I look at a woman's eyes it
was like I'm not enough so I think that
like permeated in me throughout like
being young and so I think it made
everything kind of so then anytime I got
close to a woman everything was
uncomfortable because it was like how
can I be this close and I'm okay like
I'm okay to be here and it's not like
I'm not being like feeling rejected it's
like I think it made it made everything
super just a lot of nerves in that space
you know I get it I've always felt more
of a connection with women because I was
raised and surrounded by women so I've
had to deal with like you know I've had
sisters who [__] come home after
getting raped or you know what I mean
just like the craziest [__] and I don't
know I just always like you know I see
my my mom I'm like a little boy you know
like damn you're a toddler she's getting
her [__] brains beat out of her she's
all bloody and please come and all this
[__] and I'm like oh
don't treat a woman like that you know
my dad's smoking crack and Pawn in my
[__] PlayStation and [__] oh don't
treat your child like that so I saw all
these you know my brothers running
around with guns oh try to don't do
these things and that's not me [__]
on my family like it's just right it is
what it is you know what I mean and a
lot of my family's really turned their
lives around for the most I mean
[__] still in the hood and [__]
but it's good and you know sometimes
[__] would be like hey man like
how come you don't give your money fan
your family money and it's like one I I
have and then it's gone immediately it's
like I've done that and then it's like
oh I learned my lesson immediately
because like you give somebody money
they don't know what to do with it it's
even like okay what I'm gonna buy you a
house and what I gotta pay your mortgage
for the rest of your life or I got this
I gotta so it's like you can only give
but so much to to a person because if
somebody gave me a million dollars when
I was in the hood at 18 I would just be
a Taco Bell every day oh like I would
just be like I I don't know how I'd be
doing coke dude I'd be trying to eat my
own ass oh my god dude you do enough
drugs you'll try to you'll get back
there true all right it's time to take
on the sunshine but to do it with gear
that's built to last
our friends at Shady Rays have you
covered for the warm weather ahead with
premium polarized Shades at an
affordable price
that's right Shady Rays offers a
world-class product that's just as good
as any expensive pair we've ever worn
but that's not all
Shady Rays offers the most insane
protection in all of eyewear every pair
of sunglasses is backed by lost and
broken Replacements that's right if you
lose or break your payer even on day one
they told us they will send you a brand
new pair no questions asked
exclusively for our listeners Shady Rays
is giving out their best deal of the
Season go to Shady rays.com and use code
Theo for 50 off two plus pairs of
polarized sunglasses
try for yourself the shades rated five
stars by over 250 000 people go to
s-h-a-d-y-r-a-y-s Shady rays.com and use
code Theo for 50 off two or more pairs
of polarized sunglasses after three
years away from the Octagon John Bones
Jones the marrow madman is back for UFC
285 with his heavyweight debut
get in on his title ballot against gone
uh Cyril gone and all the action on the
fight card with DraftKings Sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
UFC
new customers can bet just five dollars
on a pre-fight money line and get one
hundred and fifty dollars in bonus bets
if your fighter wins all DraftKings
customers can join the excitement in the
octagon with DraftKings same game
parlays combine multiple UFC 285 bets in
a one for a shot at an even bigger
payout
download the app now use code Theo
new customers can bet just five dollars
on a pre-fight money line and get one
hundred and fifty dollars in bonus bets
if your fighter wins this Saturday at
draftking Sportsbook with code Theo
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
applies see show notes for details but
it's interesting you say that because
yeah there's some family members of mine
that like uh it's easier to share stuff
with or like help them get something if
they're trying to get in their life and
I can help like financially and then
there's some where it's like they're not
in a space where they're kind of healthy
enough in a way where it's like yeah you
can't it's tough to if you give ten
thousand dollars to somebody who's
struggling with addiction you might
never they may die no you can't do it
yeah so some of that stuff gets a little
bit tricky my niece I'm putting her
through college right now she's one of
the ones that like really broke through
and she's doing incredible sorry what
were you gonna say yeah
um so but how are you able to like
compartmentalize that stuff and like not
get so attached to it because it seems
like you're able to like talk about
these pretty traumatic times that happen
in your life and you don't but you're
able to kind of discuss it in a way
that's like I'm not like who [__] like
yeah I think you go through that or you
never really that never really was I
definitely did but I was never like
I I mean I've had there's you know I've
I've shed some tears over like not
having a family you know what I mean
things like that but most of the tears I
shed were like having my son and like
getting married to a beautiful woman
that loves me and like giving me the
family I never had and that [__] makes
me be like wow like I'll look at my son
like this cute little three-year-old
pure soul and I'm like damn I can't
believe my parents smacked me around and
did you know could crack in front of me
you know I haven't had drug dealers in
the house cooking crack I'm breathing
this [__] in like I could never imagine
that for for my son yeah so it makes me
really happy but I think the biggest way
if I'm being quite honest how I dealt
with uh my upbringing was through music
through writing you know what I mean
because like a lot of people were scared
of therapy or this or that I've always
been I've been in therapy for 10 years
over 10 years now and it's it's helped
me a lot and it's given me a lot of
tools to break down um and better know
myself but before I you know sat down
with any professional I had to really
look in the mirror and be like yo like
what matters to you you know what I mean
what what do you want what don't you
want and that's why even with the wraps
and [__] like I didn't look at it at hip
hop and go oh yeah I'm a boats and hoes
and [__] and I didn't like I didn't
see it like that I saw it as a business
and I say with persistence determination
realism and wanting success more than
your next breath you could truly [__]
attain anything you want but big key is
realism
so I wasn't like oh I went to twenty
thousand dollar chain and I wanted to I
was like I want to create a brand and I
want to do it in a way that nobody else
is really doing it and that's why my
whole motto's Peace Love positivity it's
about being yourself and also the
craziest [__] is bro
Eminem is Eminem the goat he's the [__]
but he's not the first white rapper
there was so many before bro I'm the
first black white white looking black
guy traversing hip-hop like me and Jake
J Cole's genetic makeup the same Drake's
the same you know what I mean so many
people
so I'm like the first of my kind as well
experiencing this so when I would be
talking about things like emotions
and how it's okay to feel this and
people like shut the [__] up like and I
had to like really navigate
being comfortable in my skin and yeah
yeah because I feel like that's not a
universe where if you come with feelings
in like a rap battle it's a thank you
yeah you know that's not the Sword and
the shield you want to bring in there
it's changing a little bit though when
you see like a lot of these ver like a
lot of like um these like ciphers and
verses and stuff you see online I feel
like you you start to people get a
little bit more emo in there yeah I
guess I don't really give a [__] about
that [__] I'm just like I love music you
know what I mean like I used to be about
the freestyling and all that [__] and
like the battles and that's it's cool
it's cool but it's a lot of it's a lot
of [__] you I'm great and all this which
is systemic I still rap like that
sometimes like I'll have braggadocious
[__] like I actually had a line where I
said braggadocious flow I'm vein like an
IV so it's like it's just like little
things where
it's in us it's systemic why am I
wearing this I'm wearing this because I
never had it my people never had it so I
I like it I got it what's up look at me
in a way right it really is like you
know what I mean I like to think I'd do
it a little more so you know classic I'm
not I just try to try not to be too over
the top but if a [__] wants to
be over the top good he never had it and
if that's what he has to do but I would
rather
sleep
in my money
you know I'd rather sleep in a five
million dollar house in Malibu I'd
rather have you a nice home or something
yeah put a waffle maker get you a damn
ottoman dude I remember when I got a
[__] ottoman cuz
damn changes the game it does dude when
I sat on the couch and then my feet sat
on the couch
touchdown dude I thought I was going to
damn Heaven bro if I I would have taken
my own life right there if I could have
just to stay comfortable I got a number
you could call
um I got no dude I heard about that man
um sorry our conversation's been all
over a little bit but it's cool bro I'm
trying to I'm trying to I like it it
feels like we're just
like I'm just chilling with with a
friend so speaking of which you went to
like five [__] colleges what's up
with that yeah man I think I didn't know
what I wanted to do and I got into
comedy and it like comedy was this kind
of thing you didn't have to commit to
anything you know I had I always have
always had a lot of trouble uh
committing to stuff and so comedy kind
of made it where you have to commit I
think I didn't want to commit to a
college I just I don't know I had big
like commitment issues I think out of
the gate in the world I didn't like kind
of my environment so much that I just
didn't
I was never gonna let anything kind of
place me or
pigeonhole me or
even if it was a school you know it was
like I want to do
my own thing you know I think that's
dope I mean I feel like also if I
personally I feel that your 20s
like to like 26 27 that's the time to
just [__] your life up if you're gonna
do it like following a dream yeah like
Let It Go Because by the time you're 26
27 you're like all right [__] it I'll
put this tie on and go to this job for
the rest of my life Chase Bank or yeah
you know whatever but it's like I feel
like Enterprise Rental do whatever
you're gonna whatever your ambition is
do it now do it right now while you
still can because you don't want to look
back you know
um fully regret I say that a lot of
people you could even and I know this is
maybe look frowned upon or whatever you
could kill somebody
a lot of people are doing I would say
that's frowned upon well a lot of people
are doing seven years now oh for a
murder yeah so I'm like dude if there's
somebody that we really don't need I
mean ask some other people don't just
[__] pick somebody in your area yeah
but you know get a small consensus and
look dog if you think it's gonna help
Humanity bro you only you know people
are doing seven years wait a second how
did we just go from
following your dreams to murdering
people and only getting seven years it's
rap music Dude That's What It Is Well
actually one thing I did want to also
ask because we were talking about
emotions and [__] so as a as a comic you
know as a [__] genius comedian which
you are you know you're so quick you're
witty you're on your [__] has there ever
been a time
where you were like going back and forth
with another comedian and they actually
and this is it's not a two-part question
but more of a description and they
actually like [__] like legitimately
hurt your feelings or is it more so like
[__] I've been bested in this comedic
duel
or both that's a good question man I
think I've invested in a comedic though
for sure about like guys like you know
I'll be I'll get around like Shane
Gillis sometimes and just who he is
makes me laugh or if I'm having like a
rough day
um [__] one day I've been eating I went
on a new diet or you didn't eat any
calories or something for like a week so
I could barely even breathe you know
like I couldn't even open my eyes that
good and I had to do an episode with
this kid Bryce Mitchell right and he
seemed like this like
I thought he was like a wizard you know
and he's like a UFC guy like he's a very
interesting dude I don't think people
would say he's a wizard though and he's
I've like had no energy so I was like I
felt pretty best in that day
I think sometimes there's times where
you get
with comedy I think it's good with
podcasting because you can do the
conversations again
I would uh
but I think doing something like rapping
that kind of thing feels really scary
because people judge bars of raps and
stuff all the time yeah they don't do
that with comedy nobody's like oh dude
Larry had some [__] bars over here you
know yeah you know it's like they're not
doing that so uh they might say when
somebody has a couple of good jokes but
um that would be scary to me to be like
okay I'm gonna rest on these lines and
put them out has there been something
you put out where you're like
because I put out some specials around
like I know that the recording that
night wasn't the best I know that like
after the audio came out I'm like these
people I was working with didn't do
didn't capture it the best I know that I
probably could have been in a better
position and taking care of myself
better the weeks leading up to it so I
was putting out something as good as I
could
um but with your work
you gotta feel like
you get a chance to be like okay this is
it is there ever a point where you like
started something and by the end you
were like [__]
but I still got to put it out no I would
never put out something if I like wasn't
behind it like if I wasn't behind even
if it's like some fun [__] or because
that that was one thing that was really
tough to navigate through this last
decade because uh you know I'm known as
a [__] Lyricist like I rap you know
but I've also broken out of that box and
made pop music I've made trap music I've
sang I've done Indie records I've done
all types of stuff because I just that's
me I want to do different [__] you know
it's like you've acted you're you have a
podcast you're so much more than just uh
you know just a comedian quote unquote
yeah you know and that's how I felt
about myself so the the hardest thing
was was navigating like people what
other people thought and what other
people said because I did care and
because I wanted to be accepted so much
like I literally it was so obvious and
apparent but that's because I love
hip-hop and it's a beautiful space but
the thing is I was always accepted by
the greats the people in this you know
industry whether it's Wu-Tang Clan Nas
like so many people that I've come into
contact Q-tip you know I mean we've
worked with all of them yeah and they
give me my flowers and it's really
amazing but for so long I was so focused
on like well I want to be accepted by I
don't know like the taste maker or
somebody with a [__] podcast yeah
it's like [__] them in their podcast I
rap right and and when I or any [__]
Hardy and any [__] hard in a Honda
Accord with [__] loud pipes on that
[__] dude it's like oh [__] does that
guy like me you know no that's a real
thing that's what I'm saying that's a
real thing that would be like that's the
dude it's like instead of really if if
you know if the greats are giving you uh
your rewards but I'm still listening to
this [__] driving by and he's
listening to Nelly still I'd be like
[__] dude I got I'm missing somebody I'm
missing him you know I love Nelly but
I'm just saying yeah it's like I'm
missing something you know I get it I
think
um having my son do you have children
having my son really
totally open my eyes about how much [__]
doesn't [__] matter right like my son
this thing that came out of my nuts is
healthy and happy so Joe Schmo talking
[__] about me like who gives a [__] also
it's like I'm rich
and I'm famous
and you're talking about me like good
job like bro you did it like mission
accomplished you you meet you met the
green lizard alligator at the end of the
[__] game like you did it and so uh
for me that realization and this is just
in the last last few years because my
biggest thing was I used to be so upset
that it hurts when people would say mean
things about me which they do on the
internet all the time he's crazy I hope
your baby dies your wife's ugly and when
you see that every day every day all
these different things just people that
[__] that people spew out it can [__]
affect you and so I used to be so angry
like [__] like why does this hurt why
does this hurt and then I realize it's
like bro it hurts because you're a human
being and you have emotions and when I
stop being so hard on myself and I was
like bro it's okay that it hurts what
you're in control of is how long will
you let that affect you and how much
will you let it affect you and now if I
see some [__] if I subject myself to
being on the internet and I see some
[__] I just kind of just like hmm [__]
this guy and that's it and it's pretty
cool but it used to keep me up like so
what helped you turn there because
that's really some AAA type stuff it's
like you know if I sit there and read
something about it and I feel start to
feel a certain way that's normal that
kind of can happen but if I sit there
and continue to feel that way then I'm
doing that to myself at a certain point
I don't realize it this that thing is
the instigator but if I'm sitting there
and still thinking about it then that's
a choice that I'm making really at a
certain point we're still going through
it right because I used to I'm not crazy
bro I used to go and like people would
be like oh you're amazing I love your
comedy I love I love your your albums I
love and it's just so much love I love
you I love you but then we look and it's
like you [__] suck and it's like oh
my God you looked at the guy and you
look at him he's [__] 14 plays Xbox
he's a [__] and you're like they're like
this whole re this thing when like deep
down like it doesn't matter why are we
doing it starts up but I think a big
part of it is um what it what it means
to be human and adaptation so when you
think about like us [__] on like an
African plane thousands of years ago oh
yeah like big buck Connor type [__] type
beat and when we walk out of the brush
like nobody's going wow
look at these beautiful clouds look at
this Scott no you're looking for Lions
immediately and so I think that's what
we do on like today fast forward we're
looking for where's the threat where's
the threat
um and now I'm just kind of like man
I I honestly don't know why the [__] I I
cared so much for so long you know what
I mean well it would make sense I feel
like you cared if you're looking for I
mean I feel like especially as children
especially growing up you're probably
looking for adoration everybody wants to
be seen or accepted yeah I don't know
you've seen I've adapted pretty well
yeah yeah it's not like it was ever
terrible but there was just times when
it was but and the reason I love to to
discuss things whenever I uh such as
this whenever you know we kind of reach
the subject for people out there it's
just like bro you're not alone like it's
a real thing not to sound cliche but
like everybody goes through [__]
everybody you go on the internet you're
gonna fight with some [__] it could
like it can it can affect you and just
the the sheer amount of [__] that we see
in process mentally daily like I don't
think humans are even supposed to be
doing that yeah like think if it's like
you know and little little Mary Jane
like this [__] didn't have Twitter and
all and just see all the [__] with all
these girls half naked by [__] 13
being over sexualized and she's like
well I need to change myself and I need
all like that [__] didn't exist well
that's uh you know I wonder a lot of
Contracting
you know and I've jerked off recently
I'm going to be honest with everybody
but I think that a lot of times we've
exhausted our sexuality so I like you
know I feel like you're you're even
maybe even through a DNA strand you're
only supposed to see so much Cooter and
everything over time and ass or whatever
I actually agree with that oh so it's
crazy that now you're having children I
think that have no sex because you
[__] you you know Ronnie the daddy or
whatever spewed it all out dude that's
why I [__] Ernie is just sitting in
the yard
[__] licking rocks and scrolling on
Tick Tock because he can't even he don't
even have anything left in him you know
it's like it's weird like whenever we
created digital media it's like we
burned it out all out of us I think
there's a lot of men out there who are
gay not even because they want to be
it's because they all the straightness
got jerked out of them over time by
looking at photography wait what yeah
if somebody wants to be [__] gay
they're just gay oh well some people are
but some you're thinking Some People
their their predecessors have just just
busted so many nuts that they or even
them but there's a difference wait no
but it's like then what you're talking
about is more so celibacy rather than a
sexual orientation I don't know man I
think we don't know the long-term
effects of some of this pornography
think about it dude like like when
you're saying back in the day you go to
maybe the store and you see a woman pick
up a melon oh yeah jerk off in the truck
and you think about it oh that was
insane every time you [__] see an
avocado salad you [__] gotta hide in
the in the in the in the Outhouse when I
was a kid I used to [__] watch anime
and I'll just be in my head thinking
about like this anime [__] with big ass
tits and I'm like 12 years old and oh
yeah bro because I didn't have anything
I didn't [__] porn I have [__]
internet you know what I'm saying I was
busting nuts to [__] pencil
drawings damn dude it was a Vibe though
I remember one time I busted so many
nuts the first time I ever busted a nut
oh yeah take a second I busted like 14
nuts I was like 12 years old and I'm
shooting ghost loads daytime or night
time
um night all night literally I it was
the first time because you know it's
like my dick would get hard this or that
I'm like 12. bro but like
your neck would get hard when my dick
would get hard a lot you like Batman
what yeah so like I was like I'm on the
Gravitron at the fair or whatever yeah
the [__] UFO literally I would I I
you know I just I'd never busted a night
and then you bust that first nut and it
like
opens your mind you're like oh my God so
I jerked off all night
and then my dick was like all fat oh it
hurts it hurt and I went to school next
day and it was like I was walking weird
and then I I came home and I was like
man I talked to my friend I was like yo
I think my dick's [__] up can you look
at it he's like what you only look at
your dick and I was like yeah man it's
all good dude that's exactly what I'm
talking about you do it so much you end
up in a gay instance what can I say what
can I say but no it was it was hilarious
he was like yeah he's just [__] up you
need to chill so I was like okay and
then I told you that yeah he was just
like yeah that's not normal man yeah you
know yeah I remember getting so much
ointment and I would pack it around my
weiner because it would like I just
exhausted its use so much and I would
get like all that Neosporin are you
being serious oh 100 and I would put it
all around it because it would hurt you
know I mean Louis CK was on here and we
talked about that about
imagine if you had a friend that was
your wiener and you just kept [__]
pet every time he was around you just
kept [__] shaking him around until he
spit up all over yeah and then he did it
and then everybody's like let him rest
let him rest you're like nah [__] get
him back oh my God how many nuts have
you busted in a day oh not that many I'm
more of a I'm more of a long I'm more of
like uh like draw it out Edge
I wouldn't even call it edging I would
just call it very lazy kind of archaic
nuts you know I think chaic nuts I think
maybe four oh man I got you beat
yeah good I can't
handle it I mean I mean I was I was just
really young it bums me out if I do it a
little bit it bums me out you know what
I'm over porn
I'm so over it with horrible they used
to have oh they said this actually seven
states push to require ID for watching
porn online Louisiana just did this and
I think this is one of the best things
that's ever been done for sure because
dude I really do think uh logic that
this this has ruined a lot of
relationships it's like it used to be a
woman was where
any fantasy you had was directed towards
your spouse
towards your wife
um and then now
those fantasies are all exhaust you that
person can't even compete with the the
the the digitality of of all this
pornography yeah what does that article
say I'm sorry is that
Gotta Love Zach I love Zach thanks bro
he's good man and I've never told him
that so I'm glad I'm actually no he's
great he is after Decades of can we zoom
in a little bit
after Decades of fretting over miners
potentially being Overexposed to
pornography online several states are
suddenly moving fast in 2023 to attempt
to keep kids off porn sites by passing
laws requiring age verification no but
that's real I mean have you ever seen
like those funny tick tocks or things
where it's like literally eighth grade
and the band's playing at lunch and then
they'll stop and then the kid does the
PornHub drum thing as like a joke and
then all the kids laugh because they
know it's it's [__] deep man because
like I remember the first time I was
exposed to pornography I was like five
years old no yeah but it was it was
print that's how old I am it was print
yeah same it was print magazine but I
just didn't understand I remember going
up to my my mother and once again she's
a huge I don't know [__] on her here but
I'm just being honest she's a [__]
hypocrite because you know I was like
what's sex
I was five years old and asked her and
she was like
that's sex and I'm like what the [__] oh
she did that she did this she just went
like that and I was like oh [__] so then
I went to my homies I was like yo check
it out I'm having sex right now and I'm
like telling all my friends and [__]
they're like what the [__]
um but yeah I mean that's not like that
bad like seeing seeing like a little
nudie magazine when you're grown no
you're growing up like but now it's
[__] deep man like I remember one of
the first times I like was on the
internet watching like 2006 2007. we're
like I didn't even know where to go and
I mean like Yahoo like just typing [__]
and like some chicks like going down on
this guy and then she like pukes all
over his dick and I'm like scarred and
I'm like oh my God like that is some
[__] people don't need to be like a
Golden Corral I know and now that's my
fetish
but it's like it's it's just a weird
thing but yeah it's overexposure man
well it's crazy but the the harm it does
to us I think that's the things we don't
know it's like that harm it used to be
you would take all those feelings and
you put them to where every time you saw
your spouse yeah fantasize about them
and if you're open if you're open you're
like hey what's up you're trying to wear
this maid outfit and yeah you know
pretend uh you know XYZ like it's just
to have those fantasies you know and my
wife she's she's super open her [__]
dad's probably watch this right now so
I'm not going to get too deep into it
but if you know what I mean yeah but no
she she's my wife man she's she's
incredible you know what I mean she she
really satisfies me and that's another
thing when I think like all through my
20s I was just like jerking off watching
porn just because it was just kind of a
thing to do not a lot not crazy like I
never had an addiction nothing like that
um you know and I've known some some
some dudes who have and have beaten that
which I think is great
um but I'm just like for what I kind of
I'm almost like saying it like saying it
all yeah and now I want to just like not
anymore
and just focus on my personal sexual
relationship with my wife not that I'm
not or haven't but just to eat even more
I think porn has been so
normalized in a way
um
which is not it's like as an adult like
to each their own you know what I mean
but I just think this [__] about making
sure that miners can't aren't really so
exposed to it I think it is important
yeah but also
somebody's it's almost like guns you
know sure you can have all the gun laws
you want XYZ I wonder what the comments
are looking like right now anyway you
could have all these gun laws whatever
but at the [__] end of the day bro
somebody really really wants to [__]
get a gun and kill somebody they're
gonna do it and they can even make a gun
3D print a fun gun and that's but that's
how I feel kind of about like porn where
it's like if an underage you know
teenager who's older wants to see that
they're gonna find a way to do it but if
you make it more difficult then I think
you're exposing less people to to
something that can essentially
traumatize them you know uh you ever
heard that show euphoria
I met someone from it one time at a
party
um
well they really talk about
in in an incredible way how um
porn has
just [__] with the youth thinking like
yeah [__] take this dick yeah like all
this and it's like that's really I mean
it's a time and place you know there's
definitely evening but you know like
your first time yeah you can't be like
that and then a girl thinks like all
this crazy and then here's the crazy
part you're not even connecting with the
other person at all now you're almost
performing
actions that you've seen so then it's
like the human connection it's totally
gone it's like we're almost it's become
weird because with porn you're almost
start to
and with everything digital you almost
start to impersonate what you've seen
yeah so now we've taken art in all forms
and some people consider porn art and
that's fine
we've taken art we've made art and now
we're watching the art we've made and
reenacting the we don't it's like we're
we're done yeah all I know is like my
first time having sex I was like [__]
Titanic wow really I was like I love you
oh my god well also I never experienced
true love like love I I I I I don't
really believe like like I love my mom
and my dad but like
not like I love my son not like I love
my wife you know what I mean it sounds
like that was a big change to you like
once you had a family kind of because
sometimes you hear that a family will
solve a lot of those old like wounds
because you suddenly have a thing that
it's not about this behind you anymore
it's obviously about in front of you
yeah and when you're loving your son you
kind of replenish that thing that you
didn't get in a weird way it's like no
not even in a weird way that is it that
is it and that's what's so crazy like
just to think you know it was gonna be
like that
um like were you scared to get into a
marriage were you scared to have a child
like those are well I wasn't scared to
get your marriage this time because I
got it right the second time oh you did
a first marriage yeah I did a first
marriage wow that was hard
um and that was just it just wasn't my
person there was no there was no like no
uh infidelity no there's no that is just
and respectfully like I won't really get
into it because that isn't my story to
tell and that's a story that I would
happily tell you you know if you over
dinner or hanging out or whatever but
publicly it's just it just wasn't my
person it wasn't right so when I found
my wife now Brittany it was just like oh
my God like she and she got it the
wildest [__] I felt like Leo like I
found the [__] when she was 19. oh yeah
you know what I'm saying Jerry Leo Lewis
dude bring up Jerry Lee Lewis he was a
pedophile but he was so excited
about that dude
but I'm just saying he was uh he married
like a damn 12 year old oh no he didn't
really yeah Jerry Lee Lewis what the
[__] I mean that kid is that wasn't me
anyway no you have a great wife no did
your wife just do a cameo in your new uh
video yeah I had a video where she
popped in I thought that was her man I
watched that was cool yeah it's fun bro
it's a nice Anthem thank you it's been
uh it's been fun
um
just being a dad and being a husband and
I also that's one thing that I love
about getting older especially in
hip-hop because hip-hop is such a young
genre it turns 50 this year and um for
me I love talking about being
a father I love talking about aging you
know because hip-hop and well pop music
in general is all about like just young
young young literally like 17 18 19 20.
like all this [__] but it's like bro I'm
[__] 33 man you know what I mean I be
getting hemorrhoids and [__] like I want
to talk about like yeah you're an adult
I want to talk about real stuff you know
what it means to invest your money
and be smart with things which your
average kid's like I don't give a [__]
let's blow the money let's go to Vegas
baby yeah but it's just like man I've
done that and I've had that and that's
cool but like it's I just love this
stage of where I am and you talk about
looking forward and in many ways I
definitely do look forward but
um so much of my career bro
um you know 10 years ago it was always I
could never be present because I was
just like oh [__] I'm broke like I'm
like my roaches have fleas [__] like I
have nothing like you know what I mean
like and so I wanted something I wanted
something and
so once you got a little more
comfortable it made things easier yeah
but yeah I'm still thinking about the
future because it's like and this is
when I started to get therapy because I
mean I understand bro I remember you
know I did I did a deal one year I made
30 million dollars wow [__] I had a
biggest panic attack on my basketball
court Flex really yeah because I was
like bro I was so poor my whole life EBT
man I [__] ate cereal with powdered
milk bro okay like I didn't have
anything like I had nothing I never had
[__] so then when I finally got it I
like [__] freaked out about it and
then I started going to therapy and I
was like what do I do what if I lose my
money and the [__] laughed at me I call
it a [__] she's my therapist she's
amazing she's she's all screaming a
down-ass [__] no but she's extra down
because the [__] is Australian so she's
down under yeah you know what I'm saying
anyway
um so she said she was like she was like
first of all you're not gonna lose your
money you're not a [__] idiot she's
like look at you you're making proper
Investments you're you're you know
you're taking care of yourself she said
but if you did
what would you do
and I was like I'd [__] grind my ass
and she's like exactly you get it back
so number one and I remember this is at
a time when um I was like going through
a lot mentally like a lot because I had
the [__] 1-800 song out you know what
I mean it's like the biggest thing in
the world and everywhere I go it's like
suicide and people are like I tried to
kill myself and my brother tried to kill
himself and my sister killed herself and
done and just everywhere I'm going it's
like all the [__] I'm like right if
people don't know there was a song that
uh Anthem that he did that was uh about
suicide prevention and just about uh
kind of loving yourself a little bit of
evolutional Health yeah yeah mental
health so go on so yeah so dealing with
all that was like
a lot
um but for me
like I had turned down a million dollar
show in Australia and I've always wanted
to go to Australia and it was literally
it was a festival and I was going to
headline the festival about 45 minutes a
million dollars wow and I turned it down
and people could be like oh you're
[__] crazy it's like bro I want to
put a bullet in my head right like I
didn't give a [__] and then so I
remember talking to my therapist
and being like Oh you know people are
gonna think I'm crazy and she goes what
do you value do you value getting on a
22 hour flight
in your mental state right now
and going all the way to a country that
you've never been that you want to go to
but this isn't how you want to do that
what do you value I was like I value
resting
and taking a [__] break so I don't
off myself and she said then do that and
when discussing money and things with
her I remember she goes
she goes listen you're always stressing
about money and you're a millionaire she
goes you know I see a few billionaires
you know what they tell me I say what
she goes they say if only I had another
billion
and I'm like yo that's deep I need to
let this [__] go I made it
and so around this time it's like 2018.
around this time and then I [__]
grind it for like another two years but
I realized man I was always looking that
like so far man like you know when I
started rapping I'm like okay I gotta
put out a mixtape put out a mixtape okay
I gotta get fans get fans okay I gotta
start touring start touring okay I need
a record deal get a record deal okay I
got to put out um put out an album okay
the second album can't flop second album
does good okay I need to and then it's
like I gotta go gold and then you go
gold okay I gotta go platinum and then
you go platinum [__] I'm almost
10 times platinum on one [__] song
like it's just a crazy it's just it
never ends and so once I made it when my
son came out the puss
and I realized I was like yo
[__] everything else I want to be as
present as I can be so like me being
here with you today it's why I did my
research you know what I mean it's why
I'm so happy and honored that you would
let me on this show I can't believe bro
I've been doing this [__] for 10 years
and people like you are want to sit down
with me it's incredible so now every
single day of course I have goals
Ambitions things that that I look
forward to but I do the best I can to
truly just be like wow this is cool and
also like I'm not [__] dying of an
illness right you know like have some
gratitude to look at some of the
positive for sure
do you know how much your subscriptions
cost
the other the other day I realized I was
spending an extra
29.99 a month
on a service that I have two of I didn't
realize I had two of them have been
going on for three years
man that broke my heart rocket money
formerly known as true bill is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place that's
right
over 80 percent dear God of people have
subscriptions they forgot about like
that streaming service you bought to
watch just one show on or that free
trial that you never even used
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com
t-h-e-o that's rocketmoney.com Theo
rocketmoney.com Theo make sure you're
not spending money that you don't have
to be one of the most exciting things
about the new year is that you have no
idea what Adventures are in store for
you
you know just a few weeks ago I ended up
in Paris France
I didn't expect it but I did
from new travel experiences to new jobs
or picking up new skills there's no
better way to prepare for 2023 than by
learning a new language with Babel
Babel is the language learning app that
sold more than 10 million
subscriptions thanks to Babel's
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language learning lessons
with Babel you need only 10 minutes to
complete a lesson so you can start
having real life conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks
that's right
with Babel you can choose from 14
different languages including Spanish
French and German
plus Babel's speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and accent
right now get up to 55 percent off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
Theo that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash t-h-e-o for up to
55 off your subscription Babble language
for Life what was the thing like why
were you all do were you able to figure
out why you were always looking towards
the future like what that was like how
that started or anything inside because
my present was always horrible growing
up yeah so it was always like I can't
wait till I'm 18. yeah no I'll get the
[__] out of my house because my house
was a war zone man you know what I'm
saying like I said [__] dramatic
yeah cooking crack cooking it so how can
you be present how can I be like oh yeah
this is so sick I am so broke right uh
yeah nobody loves me and tight yeah yeah
exactly so I was always looking ahead
you know what I mean and then now I'm
like oh my God my wife loves me my son
loves me my fans love me this is it I
can really soak this moment up even
right here I'm not even joking I'm not
trying to sound extra bro this is so
[__] cool I've wanted to do your show
for like a long time thanks dude yeah
man there's a couple there's a couple
couple shows I have when people that in
just in general that I want to spend
time with and you know and and I'm glad
that we could do this so thank you for
having me oh thanks man
um um was it so with those receptors
being weird from growing up with not
being able to like because your
receptors get closed down if people
aren't loving you and that sort of thing
right if things aren't proper if things
aren't comfortable The receptors I think
for accepting love and that sort of
thing probably get kind of damaged as a
child yeah are you able to feel that
change once you had your own family once
that I mean did or has that also been
like a work in progress because that was
a work in progress because uh my I I
always was like one day I'm gonna have a
family one day I'm gonna have a family
and then I had my my the family that I
do now and I realize holy [__] you know
my best friends
who were driving me to shows and are my
best friends to this day my producer who
made all my Beats like these were my
family this whole time as I met these
people like really blood isn't like it's
crazy you think like even think about
this like I know it sounds so stupid but
my wife's parents first of all I hit the
jackpot they're [__] Stoners and we
smoke joints together oh really yeah
they're the best anyway but like
they're my family but we're not related
like isn't that weird to think I mean
I'm not even being funny I'm just saying
like there's no we don't have the same
blood right but my son is like that's my
grandparents and that's my mom and
that's my dad like even the premise of
like a mother and a father like a
husband and wife like obviously I know
it sounds stupid I'm setting you up I'm
giving you gold but I'm saying like
they're not related
but like as a child you look at you're
like this is our family like ah like
it's so weird to process that these two
people had a whole life before it [__]
different people all types but they came
together and it's just like that's my
parents bro I never had that [__] right
I never had it
so then when I you know I meet my wife
and then we have a baby and then I'm
like whoa like this connection is a real
thing and even the connection that I
have like with other members of her
family like they really become my family
and I'm like whoa that's weird because
also even though I'm very close with a
lot of them there's some that I'm not
that close with but I'm so close with my
homies I came up with so then I'm like
well what is family it's a weird thing
and I'm still trying to process it
that's the biggest thing I I'm really
enjoying about my 30s is the lack of
like giving a [__] about external [__]
and being able to really just like live
my life they say that I feel more
comfortable truly and my skin
than ever before because I'll be I'll do
videos and I'll be all funny and stupid
yeah being like kind of just becoming
more your person a personality right for
sure than uh just a just a music or just
seeing the part of your personality that
does music I'm trying to be rap Secrets
[__] like I want to be like I
could easily see that I'm gonna be hip
hop [__] Jimmy Fallon like that's
what I want I just I don't know and I'll
still always make music but this is it
like I wanna you know come back and do
this [__] I want to go do other other
shows I want you to come [__] with me on
my YouTube [__] like I really just I
just want to make people laugh and have
fun and and educate along the way just
like you're doing this is really great
man for you to be able to crack a incest
joke one second and then talk about
serious mental health it's like dope man
you walk this really fine line which is
you should be proud of yourself well
thanks for sucking this guy's dick right
now but it's true well I can't help it
but you know try to stay be alive and be
you know do my best to just be myself
it's hard a lot of times
um I'm kind of intrigued on what you
like since you were saying if you didn't
have a family and so you I it takes
somebody like that to go through your
experience to be able to make but then
you do something you make music and
beats that bring people together which
is interesting yeah because it's so
interesting that some something that
would
somebody that didn't have something that
brings makes them feel together would
then have the propensity almost like a
mirror or flat or an inverse of it would
be able to bring people together it's
really crazy how all that works it's the
craziest part is is like you know I'm
very I'm very known for you know like I
said my positive lyrics like uplifting
lyrics letting people know like it's
gonna be all right keep persevering keep
fighting no matter what you're going
through but when I first was writing
lyrics like that it was to me so because
I didn't have anybody there I didn't
have family I didn't have friends really
to articulate and be like bro you're
okay like you'll get through like when
my mom's half naked and all [__]
bleeding and the cops are coming and
dragging a [__] down the stairs and you
know just a just the wildest [__] is
happening nobody was there to say that
so I'm writing these lyrics like don't
worry whatever you're going through
you'll get through it you know don't
worry you know uh whatever is troubling
your mind in time you're gonna find that
it's all like whatever like and I would
just get this and it would it was just
released and then over years like and
then once I kind of started popping and
when I say popping up really I mean
[__] Beyond underground like internet
days of DatPiff and free mixtapes and
YouTube and [__] like the beginning of
Twitter and I started to see people be
like man this song really resonated with
me I was like what the [__]
and that's another reason why I even
created the 1-800 song Because about
suicide prevention
is because so many people are like oh
your music saved my life I'm like what
and they're like nah for real like and
then I did this tour for my second album
where I uh I got a tour bus and
literally did a fan tour from California
to New York going to my fans houses
eating dinner with them and their
families playing them my album early and
so many of them were saying yo your
music saved my life and they would go
into detail about how and why and then I
was like whoa okay this isn't just whoa
this is crazy and then that's when I
decided to write the song 1-800 because
I was like if I selfishly
was writing these records for me and
then they've affected you people to the
point where what do you mean you people
anyway to the point where you feel like
I legitimately have affected you
but I wasn't trying what could happen if
I tried and that's what happened and
then Congress wrote me a letter and was
like
it's [__] statistics have proven that
your your song has saved lives around
the world this is wow yeah it's crazy
[__] that head of he was what'd you do
with the letter
um I got it I'm trying to frame I'm
trying to frame it I want to get it
framed like a
like a doctorate like you know when you
become a doctor and it's like on that
like thick raised paper I want that [__]
that's one thing that gets hectic about
like when your life gets busy is all the
things you want to frame and have it
framed yet it's like it was kind of like
I mean I know it sounds crazy that's one
of the toughest things there's a pile of
about four things at home that I want to
frame and one day I will I got a lot of
pictures too with people like I've been
so blessed to meet so many people and
then I'll remember and I'll tell my
assistant I'm like yo find that picture
of me and Stevie Wonder
like for real or get to joining me and
Kobe or hey can you get the [__] of the
time I met Chappelle and he bought me a
drink like I literally just all these
Sarah Silverman like dude I'm so lucky
to like me hey bro we're gonna take a
picture after this I'm framing it what
the [__] thinking yeah it's going to
my house bro do you
um so being black and white is that
that's got to be like the [__]
coolest I feel like but is it scary
sometimes like do you feel black and
white or do you just feel one thing yeah
must be good
I feel like me I know that sounds cliche
I just I feel like me but I do
um
like if you walk past like a barbecue
spot do you feel like part of you comes
to the edge of your skin
yeah you know what I'm saying like do
you feel some sales kind of scoot over
to it and if you walk past like a um a
cop do you feel those same cells like
kind of move to the 100 but the craziest
part is is like because here here's
here's a fact whether whether you
[__] like logic or not or whether
you're like whatever it's like for I
don't give a [__] I'm not here to argue
because you know there's people who's
like well you don't you'll never
understand what it's like to walk down
the street as a black man and I'm like
yo all right I want you to shut the [__]
up yeah because you'll never understand
what it's like to walk down the street
as a black man in a white man's body and
it and then wait wait let me Shut the
[__] up why are we arguing yeah you're
like Mrs Doubtfire but that's what I'm
saying why
hello why are we arguing in the first
place what you what you're going through
I'm not denying what you're going
through [__] all that [__] so for me
it's like yeah it's a crazy thing like
yeah and I love it you know
[__] used to always be like oh
you he talks about this all the time I'm
like so the [__] what man I don't give a
[__] I'm proud I like it you know what I
mean you look at [__] Twitter
bio and there should be like black and
proud [__] I'm biracial I'm
proud but I do feel I definitely code
switch a lot you're familiar with this
term uh-oh code switching is like if I
was going into into like a [__]
interview or some [__] I'm like well
hello there sir yes I really like this
job I I really appreciate that thank you
so much oh excuse me I have one call
[__] what the [__] man you got my [__]
what you know what I mean so it's like
that it is a part of you it is almost
like you kind of feel like like two
different people but that's one thing in
the culture as well it's like any
anybody who's of the culture who meets
me IRL not some [__] anybody who
[__] really meets me shakes my hand
they know what's up because it's not a
thing why would it even be a thing it's
not a thing it's only a thing on the
internet it's only a thing on the
internet like I've never met anybody and
they're like no you're not you're not
like because it's not a thing
it's not a thing it's not a thing it's
like I definitely love to let people
know who I am
so yeah when I meet somebody if they're
like tell me about yourself first thing
out of my [__] mouth black dad white
Mom Dad I grew up broke it's just it's
it's my [__] identity there's no
identity crisis this is who the [__] I
am and I know well it's also it's a
responsibility in a weird way as you get
older it's like you become this piece of
an important time when people are
discussing stuff and they want to know
what things feel like and they want to
know like
you know and some people that don't know
how to relate like I like always was
envious
I always was envious of black kids
growing up like I grew up in like a half
and half neighborhood right and I was
real envious of black kids because
I mean this may sound crazy but
I like
they at least had an excuse for how
people treated them and looked at them
in a weird way and it's not an excuse
but I understand they like and then it
was like if you were poor and white it
was like you just [__] up somehow it
was like how what the [__] how did you
[__] up you know like you didn't that's
like the white privilege thing which I
agree with I think white Privileges and
there's always more to it exactly
there's always so much more to it it's
like you're just talking in like a
specific moment but I always was like
man I feel it was because I felt
sometimes a similar way that some of my
black friends felt yeah but because you
guys are of you're of the culture bro
that's what I'm saying culture to me
when I say of the culture I'm not
talking about skin color I'm not talking
about none of that [__] it's like I grew
up with Salvadorian kids and black kids
and white kids and Asian homies and we
were all from the same place we talked
the same bro there was white home there
was white people in our Clique and it'd
be like 14 black dudes three white guys
and in my biracial ass and all the white
the white boys would say [__] they do
that's what they did they would say it
because the black dudes are like hey say
that [__] set you down like that's the
internet is a spray painted on my legs
sometimes I remember what and I was like
this is [__] what the [__] I don't
want it this bad but
yeah it's it's a it's a it's a crazy
thing but that's what I mean of the
culture is like you understand that
plight of like you know uh just well I
mean did you grow up poor yeah yeah so
then growing up broke and and and and
and longing four things and one thing
and then having that connection so it's
like damn you know like I never had the
PlayStation right like I mean I did like
later but I had like the like when
everybody was on like the PS3 and [__] I
finally got my PlayStation yeah type
[__] so yeah yeah yeah but but that's
that's a big thing I think um
all this fighting on the internet of
what is this or that because there's no
like there's no voice there's no like
ambassador of black people like you know
what I mean or white people or this or
Asian people like just because one black
dude or white guy or says something it's
like they don't [__] speak for an
entire race of people yeah let alone
almost what you could consider like a
denomination or just a a a a group
of people in a specific place because
also like racism in America is so
different from racism in Europe or this
or that or that uh like you know people
have their different experiences with it
in ways that we could never understand
oh totally yeah yeah I could never
understand what it was like to be what
it's like to be something different than
what I am you know I could try in
moments you know I think one thing that
I envied about black uh and it was
mostly guys that I knew I didn't know a
lot of black girls when I was a kid but
um just their origin story they had like
an origin story you know it felt like
they had like a history and a purpose
and like it sounds like we're talking
about a [__] Marvel movie what do you
mean but that's what it felt like it was
like
it was like if I don't know black it
just felt like they had like a
they were coming from a place
it was obvious that they were coming
like making they had to make a comeback
in a way oh yeah
I was like what the [__] where is
this going yeah it's a hundred percent I
mean right because they had like a
[__] like they had like a thing that
everybody knew that was obvious and it
was like I think I always envied that a
little bit it was like I feel like why
why would you envy because I feel some
of these ways but uh Nobody Knows It by
looking at me I get it but that's
different but once again that isn't
really so much of a race thing like even
though what you're talking about yeah
that's like [__] 400 years of slavery
and oppression and [__] yeah 100 like
that's some deep [__]
but what you're talking about is like
the plight of man bro like you came up
with these people in your own way though
you you definitely don't have the same
lineage or history right that goes into
a lot of emotion confusion need for
Education you know that black folk have
about themselves
um and just you know whether it would be
uh you know someone in Latin culture as
well experiencing their own thing so but
aren't you what what's your father my
father's from Nicaragua yeah but I've
perceived mostly as white but I mean
aren't you biracial yeah but I don't
have a dual citizenship you know any
decision [__] [__] DNA what you
talking about DNA is your citizenship
like you're yeah so you're mixed
technically yeah so was your father
light-skinned no he was dark skinned
kinda
welcome to the club [__] what the [__]
you mean but that's what I mean so you
but do you perceive yourself as white
no people call us like uh my brother's
real dark skinned and people would call
us like uh
uh like uh what do they call oh Puerto
Ricans when I was growing up that was
like the big thing that everybody called
y'all Puerto Rican yeah they didn't have
any Mexicans back then so for some
reason some people are so important
that's how I thought about Maryland
there's like no Mexicans there's just a
bunch of salvadorians yeah and I was
just eating papooses all the time
they're so fire but wait
we had a group called whites against
Mexicans actually in our town for a
little bit but we didn't have any
Mexicans
so it was just like I think they kind of
roughed up this Chinese kid once what
the [__] okay wait a second hold on so
how do you perceive yourself or at least
how did you growing up did you perceive
yourself see myself as white because I
think my dad was so old I was so
embarrassed of anything to do with him
that I didn't want to know about it or
learn about it you know I mean my dad
grew up in a village where
people would eat dirt they didn't have
anything to eat and they would eat dirt
and get sick and die all the time I
remember him telling me stuff about that
um
but I didn't care I I think I rejected
him so much in a weird way because he
was so much older that it was every time
he was around even though I longed to
like kind of know him more I think it
was so embarrassing once I kind of
became like of age where I knew what my
friend the looks on their face isn't
that so annoying too like no but not
even [__] those kids but just you that
you were so young and that gets almost
like imagine not to right but if I could
be me now exactly and I would accept it
and just talk about all the things that
you could learn but
it's all good you know what I mean
that's that's that's life and and that
that's where you uh where you stood and
you were a kid you were being normal
though it's not like you were like some
piece of [__] you know what I mean it's
like you know you were just like dead
like you know what I mean it's it was
right it was normal yeah it was like dad
dropped me off around the block like
don't don't pull up so I get that
um they had what was that or did you see
the thing they had Zach if you can pull
it up it was about they just had some
kids that got in trouble they had a
Salvadorian
caretaker the only thing I'm talking
about in Miami
the second graders it was a black face
incident that they had what the what
yeah yeah we were talking about this or
two or what are the two-year-olds yeah
so there's a Miami preschool it's kind
of getting some Flack because they put
two-year-olds in like blackface for
Black History Month what
at least they gave them jobs and [__]
though I mean
yo you're kidding no but here's what
happened there's a Salvadorian can you
find the people that run this preschool
in Miami are from Argentina so they
don't know the culture here as much oh I
understand so this was Black History
Month so they were just so they had
these kids and they some of the white
kids they wanted them to be able to be
black and so and then you got these
little innocent little kids that don't
know what the [__] is going on all the
crazy is they blurt the kid's face out
like oh yeah like that's gonna make it
different that makes it look even worse
it looks like 8-bit [__] yo that's
that's wild only black face I've ever
really
personally experience
um is this Rolex I got oh gang yeah this
[__] is dope yeah it's actually in
Japanese kanji too which is uh which is
a Vibe is that a uh let me see it's from
Tokyo oh dang that's nice huh thank you
and is that stone inside of it
what you mean what's in the inside of it
Oh you mean like what is the what is it
the black [__] made out of I don't know
it might be Onyx or something I don't
[__] know
because this show yeah because well the
um yeah the blackface stuff comes from
like menstrual shows they had like I
think it was like 200 150 years ago they
had like shows where they wouldn't let
black performers perform so they made
them so they made white people they had
them put black stuff on their face right
so I think that's where a lot of the
obviously the origins of people being
against it you know that it makes people
feel uncomfortable yeah I just wonder if
at a certain point like if it's a
two-year-old kid
what the [__] does he you know what it's
like yeah but but a two-year-old kid
ain't applying blackface to himself all
right that's true there's an adult doing
that like let's just be real no you know
what I'm saying what the [__] first of
all what that's true where does this kid
have accent access to paint or shoe
polish like they was doing back in the
day like where like it's no this is this
is an adult now this specific thing it's
like oh okay they were it was like a
Latin situation they didn't know like it
is what it is you know what I mean but
besides that do you think there will
ever be a time where it's like say a kid
who loves you know Derrick Rose is his
favorite athlete he's an eight-year-old
he can Dr he can
put on makeup if he wants he can darken
up a little bit or Urban out a little
bit to go out trick-or-treating you know
what or he can like the urban out I mean
he could get like Urban out I mean urban
out right now yo you got where's the
shoe polish that's Urban out what the
[__] I don't know I'm just saying do you
no okay of course not you can't [__]
what the [__] kind of [__] is that you
can't do that [__] man now it the
difference is though it's like if you're
Robert Downey Jr I think that shit's
hilarious like if you're if you're a
[__] actor it's a gig it's a job it's
a bit you know you're [__] Chappelle
you're you're like what like it's
[__] if this is what you do right you
know I mean because I'm gonna be real
bro like like comedians I feel like I
don't even yep there it is there it goes
now don't get me wrong that's the most
racist [__] ever but that's why it's
[__] hilarious let's just be real
anybody who's watched Tropic Thunder
it's like you gotta understand they're
actually making fun of the racism of
Hollywood at the time by casting a white
guy to play a black guy who's really
another guy and a guy with another guy
yeah survive survive like and that's
just like man when I was 18 years old
and I watched that I was like this is
[__] hilarious right um but it's I
believe that the [__] was done right it
was tasteful it was this it was it was
all I mean even when there's a moment in
the movie when he's like
a white character is talking to him as
he's in blackface and he's like some
some you people and he's like what do
you mean you people and then and then
the black home he's the actor he's like
what the [__] you mean that's funny bro
that's funny and so question for you as
a comedian like
where do we draw the line because I feel
like shit's easing up a bit and I think
I think with the it I know we all know
where it started Harvey Weinstein me too
movement cancel culture like it became
this crazy almost over correction but
I'm happy it happened just because like
there's a lot of [__] pieces of [__] in
the industry that we're getting away
with a lot of stuff now there's a big
difference between like I made a little
mistake or whatever and then just like
straight up rape and things like that so
it was I think it was really good that
that happened but then you know yeah a
hundred percent it was it was incredible
that these women were given a voice and
giving power and you know taking back
power that was essentially stripped from
them which is disgusting and that's
something I've dealt uh seen the women
in my life deal with personally so yeah
I got that now fast forward you know a
couple years and then you're just making
jokes and [__] like I saw this one girl
they was trying to cancel this girl in
high school I was watching you know h3h3
you ever yeah it's like yeah Ethan Klein
yeah Ethan so like Ethan did this not
bit but you know you know and he did
this thing thing where he's talking
about this this little white girl who's
wearing a like a kimono prom dress and
then everybody's like that's cultural
appropriation like this girl's not
allowed to wear a kimono she's not
Japanese like all this [__] right and I
was just like God damn this is [__]
crazy because I'm like wearing a I'm
like wearing a [__] Komodo watching
this [__] because I because I went to
Japan
and I'm [__] doing an album in Japan
and I'm like where am I [__] you know I
think I'm turning in Japanese like I'm
[__] vibing it over there and I'm
supporting the economy I'm buying it's a
[__] little Japanese woman who's like
you know half the Dominic have this
thank you very much and I'm like oh
that's dope does that mean I'm
culturally what the [__] like I don't
know now this is a hot take but I'm just
simply saying
that's kind of crazy you know what I
mean yeah like she it wasn't like she
was like straight traditional even even
Nino but it was just like she was just
like wearing a cute little a little
thing and they was just trying to
destroy this this girl so as a comedian
how do you feel when people be really
like did you see what happened to you
know Troy Bond you know who Troy bond is
uh um bring him up yo you don't know
Troy Bond Troy Bond yo okay first of all
Troy bond is the future of Comedy is he
really he this kid yeah
[__] he's on he's on Tick Tock
he's incredible and if you go to it you
might be able to see it here uh if you
go to his yeah keep scrolling down you
should it's uh [__] they're like I met
him before he's a gay gentleman no he's
not gay
but uh he he does refer to himself as a
Puerto Rican lesbian but he's actually
black and white he made a joke about how
he looks like looks like that uh yeah he
looks like that killer remember who
Jeffrey Ronnie Rodriguez or whatever oh
the [__] um yeah what was that guy
the guy the [__] you talking about
the Zodiac no not the Zodiac I think
it's Ronnie Rodriguez we go from Troy
Bond
dude Somebody's gotta kill bro I'll tell
you this they uh yeah what the [__] no
that's not you're thinking Ramirez
Ramirez Ronnie Ramirez you're thinking
of Ramirez the [__] whatever Ronnie
Ramirez the Zodiac salesman or whatever
but listen so if you I don't know if you
have Tick Tock up there if you can go to
tick tock or if somebody can try to get
you this clip because I think it's
really important that you show it on the
show and the reason is is because so
he's black and white okay I'm gonna be
honest he he looks like he could he
could be white or something else or you
know he's kind of like yourself like
ambiguous yeah and so he's doing this
um this great set
mm-hmm
we'll find it we'll find it he's doing
this great set and this girl
screams at him and she's like that's so
[__] racist blah blah blah blah and
she doesn't even know yeah that he's
that he's mixed you get a lot of that in
clubs these days so I'm just like why
the [__] would you go to the club to a
comedy show you see the bill you know
pretty much who's going to be there that
night who's got time you know I've only
ever been to a comedy club once we'll
talk about that in a bit but
what is that like well I think this is
what's happened I think this is what's
happened I think you have I don't think
you have as much racism in the world as
you did 25 years ago I really don't I
think what you have these days you have
a lot of division that happens from
people's like online you have a lot of
people that have marketed the past and
it's great to be reminded by the past
undeniably right we still have a lot of
recovering to do from the past I think
some cultures even genetically they have
to work it will take time for their DNA
to heal from traumas of the past no
doubt but I think now you get a lot of
the past marketed like packaged in the
clips into like movies where you're
constantly reminded of of like the
[__] up things of the past to the
point where some people that just
becomes their identity now so they don't
have any real like human connection to
it they just have this sort of like
it's almost like I don't want to say
it's an educational connection but it's
just like oh I see this that's racist
there's no I don't have any texture to
it there's no like history to it for me
it's just something that I see now
online and I know that that's supposed
to what's also crazy to me is the is the
hit when there is history ties so for
example I wrote this movie script a
couple years ago called Jerry about a
homeless comedian who tells jokes on
Venice for a dollar okay and one night
he's he's telling stand-up jokes all
types of jokes he's telling black jokes
white jokes gay jokes it's just being
funny he's being himself okay Jerry and
he makes a joke about I forget it now
but it's something along the lines of
like oh man could you imagine if like a
South Central
um blood had leukemia he would be like
the illest uh blood of all time because
it's a blood condition anyway it's a lot
funnier with the wearer that I wrote it
and in this in the uh in the crowd it
took me a second yeah and the crowd
um this woman who was laughing
hysterically stops and starts heckling
the man heckling the man heckling man
and then she's just like how could you
possibly say that and he doesn't even
argue with her
and his manager Mike
um which is the character I'd like to
play uh is like dude why didn't you say
anything to that woman and he goes you
know a lot of people tend to be
Hypocrites she she's a white middle-aged
white lady she wants to laugh at black
jokes she wants to she's straight she
wants to laugh at gay jokes he's like
it's very apparent it's either her her
mom her dad somebody died of a blood
disease bro it was this or that and it
was just really cool
because I I've taken my own experience
when writing that about what triggers
people and what I've seen trigger people
and I just think it's really kind of
annoying
that people like to pick and choose
don't get me wrong you know it's like
it's almost like if somebody was to make
a Parkinson's joke you know I actually I
made I made a joke
um I I had a my mind you don't
Parkinson's I don't but I'll tell you
I'll tell you something it's actually
wild so a gentleman named Chewie does
all my tattoos I met him through track I
saw him on your Instagram yeah yeah yeah
yeah and so he asked me to give him a
tattoo so he did that Metal Gear Solid
when it took about six or seven hours
exactly yeah you spent your time you
care you just look that's a cool one
actually it reminded me of that game too
I love that game so Wu-Tang I have a
Wu-Tang um tattoo right here and he was
like I want you to give me a Wu-Tang
tattoo and this is like five years ago
and I jokingly I'm like y'all don't want
to see that [__] it looks like Michael J
fox did it because it's all squiggly oh
yeah bad off but I go I go don't worry I
can make that joke it's kind of like
saying the n-word and I was like because
I'm black and I said because I have
dystonia so uh dystonia I I have
cervical dystonia I don't have a cervix
cervical is uh it's your neck and
basically my head shakes like this
really yeah it goes like this like you
got that remixing you've got that like
it's crazy and so
um I have to go get botox injections in
my neck no yeah deep in my it's why my
neck looks like such a young bad [__]
no they go deep in there it's why Botox
was invented and so they go all the way
in to weaken the muscle because my
muscle I know bro it's [__] trying to
put you down when you do it no I do it I
do it every three months I'm supposed to
like my [__] right now like running
behind huh yeah it's shaking a little
bit now so I gotta do it and you need to
get over there but what I'm saying is
he's like bro
people die of Parkinson's disease you
know Ryan Reynolds father passed away
like he had to experience that so it's
like when I make a joke like that
um I think it's really how it's just
it's just how you do it like that's a
man's pain bro you know what I mean we
all love Michael J fox [__] Micah
Smith fly man's Marty like we love
Michael J fox I love Michael J fox and
in no way would I ever try to hurt
somebody this or that it that's honestly
my pain that's like me like the fact
that if I didn't have these shots in me
right now or even my thumbs my thumbs
[__] shake like it's these things
that that are insecure and that give me
emotional pain and sometimes physical
pain and in a way I used comedy in that
moment to like
cope
and with a man that I can relate to to
some degree not to that degree obviously
and I just think it's kind of crazy that
if you're a good comedian no if you're a
[__] great comedian you use pain and
you use trauma such as Chappelle and
your prior and so many great people to
talk about the hard things and so I
think I love Chappelle because no matter
what the [__] got hot takes
like I did it I love great comedians
because they will [__] on black people
white people Asian people straight
people gay people Chinese
every and they have us all laughing with
us at each other like it's fun it used
to be like that bro
I mean it is with cats like you and who
step out and they're like [__] that and
you say what you want because like the
thing is is like I love Chappelle and I
feel like the [__] like damn
near uncancelable I used to think Kanye
was uncancelable
I really believed it until Kanye and I
love Kanye you know it's just like yo
he's mentally he's ill you know and it's
like I literally was like there's
nothing he was wearing a white lives
Matter t-shirts I'm like there's nothing
Kanye West can do and he's doing
snorkeling he did pictures of him
snorkeling he did the two things
that you don't do one of two one of two
he didn't do the two things he did one
of two things that you don't do that
could get you canceled
sex [__] that you shouldn't be doing
whether it's underage or this he did
that no he didn't do that oh I said one
of two so don't miss [__] quote me
now okay
or [__] be racist
and he's but he was racing against Jews
that's what really got him no I know 100
but I'm still saying tried every other
race to be racist against I feel like
yeah but I'm just no no no no I I think
the the one there is something to be
said about yeah it's just like bro
that's a group of people just in general
that are [__] they they are killing
in Hollywood like you know what I'm
saying like yeah yeah like it's just a
real in a great way cool whatever [__]
it good for them yeah but like why would
you say not even that take that [__] out
of it right okay bro you're talking
about you know Hitler was kind of cool
right I think there's something he got
addicted to something about pushing
buttons I think that's what it was I
agree I mean from the hat to all this
other [__] and it's like whatever man
it's cool but I just that was a sad
thing that was like such a hard thing to
see because I'm just like man that's one
that's the one thing like legitimate
like hate like hate hate speech hate
this hate that it's like bro you could
have pretty much said anything but you
backed Hitler like you can't do that
yeah you can't back Hitler dude I mean
even if he you know
ever you know yeah you cannot do it yeah
it's Hitler yeah I mean yeah it's Hitler
it's like there's like four guys you
can't back Hitler Satan
Weinstein I think yeah definitely
definitely that and uh and I don't know
who else maybe that Wiley Coyote guy
whichever one's the bad one on that
um I love it but yeah I think that that
was crazy but here's one thing that
happened with the Kanye thing that also
got weird is like if he's mentally
unwell right do you think he's mentally
unwell yes right so what a sir I don't
think he's [__] I don't think he's
crazy right he may be mad he may have
some different issues I think yeah I
think he's bipolar and I think he's but
he's mentally unwell I don't think he's
like [__] crazy like I'm not writing
my man off I love this dude he's changed
my life yeah I never even met him you
know so anyway please I just want to
make that very clear like I'm not hot
take just trying to use Kanye's name not
a [__] Tick Tock oh I think yeah I
wish Rihanna would have brought him out
at halftime I think that would have been
crazy wouldn't it yeah but you know her
folks were like yeah also it's just like
he did is that where he really needs to
be right now on stage in front of the
entire world right but but that's
exactly what goes into my point I was
gonna make is that or that I was gonna
bring up is that at what point should
the media stop putting some dude out
there if they know he's mentally unwell
the same media that has run in
advertisements for like people are
mentally unwell get help get help and
then they're taking somebody even if
that guy's making a clown of himself
right if you know in your heart that
part of him is not well and you continue
to publicize him every day every moment
everything he says
like that's kind of sick it is but
that's our culture that's what we live
in man you know we love to see I I've
even had it at a different scale of
course but like just my rise like I was
the underground Underdog everybody wants
that [__] Underdog to win and then
when they win it's like oh he's killing
it killing it but like
they want you to fall yeah they really
do that's in a movie it only works like
that yeah and I've fallen but it's
almost like perception like have I
really Fallen like I'm [__] I've made
good Investments monetarily family yeah
exactly so it's like but there is a
thing where it's like oh he's whack now
you know and it's like oh logic's whack
and then you drop another album they're
like Logics back yeah the logic's whack
watch it back and then I'm just uh then
this is where I've finally found this
place where I'm like I give a [__]
logic's rich and happy like that that's
all that matters
um
I could talk to you all day and I want
to talk to you all day I gotta pee all
right let's pee and we'll come back and
do another half hour all right
oh man yo how about P drips oh [__] I
feel like I used to shake it I don't own
anymore I keep it I just let it go right
into the pant nah man I gotta shake it a
little bit but yeah you're right you're
right it's just annoying but whatever P
drips it's like
anyway I how much do you sleep do you
are you able to sleep fully through the
night or you got to get up and pee well
oh I P I get up every night 100 wow
every night yeah because I'm hydrated
like I love I drink a lot of water and I
used to I mean I'm at the tail end of
college because well I never went to
college but I also that's the total
attitude of somebody who never went okay
I just mean like drinking what the [__]
alcohol hurt that statement of My Life
alcohol 33 is like I'm at the tail end
of college bruh like about time bruh
yeah I never drank really or smoothly
yeah my whole life until I was like 27
28. what so was that because your
parents were addicts you think 100 yeah
yeah without without doubt wow and then
um because I was like
I can't let this [__] me like literally
my friends would be like man just hit
the weed I actually just released the um
a video yesterday about this it's like
an anime that is kind of a part of a
trailer for This Album College Park
that's dropping and anyway uh so I was
just so scared that it would affect that
and then when I made that 30 million I
was like well I did it
let's do Coke no I'm just kidding no I
was like I did it okay cool and then I
just I started to enjoy uh all I don't
do anything hard and I don't judge
anybody does but I do uh I just I love
scotch and I love uh I Love Weed and
I just started doing that and then I did
it pretty pretty good and then like 2020
like through covid I was getting [__]
wrecked really yeah I mean there's
nothing else to do I had my baby and
whatever but I was like just hung over
all the time for like two years I was
like perpetually hungover because I
never did it I never I never did it I
finally did it but it wasn't like bro I
actually have a song in this album you
know and I go uh you know I wake up
seven days a week and get the job done
you know you know I'm always there for
my wife and my son but at the end of the
day I love to pour one more like two but
occasionally three and it scares me not
because I have a problem I'm the type of
person if there's an issue then I'ma
solve them it's more like seeing how
this [__] has destroyed life I look at
my mom I look at my dad and it's just
it's it's a it's a crazy thing man so I
saw that um and I I do I get I get the
job done I did my thing but now I'm just
I'm at the tail end of it because I yeah
I just and I say this to say like my
whole sleep schedules changed because it
just as a musician I used to be up till
5 30 in the morning wake up at 1pm I was
saying that I was in bed with my wife
the other day and it was two and I was
like dude dude if this was two years ago
it'd be 11 p.m for me right now it was
two it was 2 p.m in the afternoon and so
yeah when you make the 30 million what
was they bought your catalog no that was
a deal that I did I did a long-term
attorney deal yeah wow yeah yeah
and on top of that I re-upped with my
deaf with Def Jam because now I'm
independent but I re-up with Def Jam and
they gave me some nice M's as well so it
was all like within a week of each other
oh yeah which is crazy did you get one
eight ball even no yeah I've never done
I've never done Coke really I've never
done anything hard my God boy I'll
[__] do it for you
all right I will if you need somebody to
just tag me into so wait are you sober
yeah I got 10 months right now wow so is
it hard
what's hard for me is if I think about
women sometimes that's my trigger
it's women it's affection that's my
trigger that would make me do drugs and
I don't drink because I'm afraid I might
I would buy cocaine I don't have a
drinking problem I don't even like
drinking I don't like pizza
I don't it's so dumb oh my God this
feels a little bit because it feels
almost kind of like
not homoerotic but I feel like it's like
you're Wild
it almost feels like kind of like pervy
like you're making your own weather and
it feels like you're touching your
wiener at the same time or whatever
right but I don't think it like I don't
like it doesn't uh it's bores me after a
while it's like I don't want to be doing
this I would rather do something else
that I haven't done honestly that's how
I feel because I quit I smoked
cigarettes since I was 11. and I smoked
cigarettes yeah I smoke cigarettes from
11. Baltimore National Anthem isn't it
smoking [__] cigarettes Newports
Newports at that oh dude I would smoke
cigarettes with my mom glass lung Bobby
I would smoke cigarettes with my mother
I remember when I was up I was 11 years
old and I was like I'll never forget
this I was watching Fresh Prince and I'm
sitting on the carpet it's dirt dusty
ass carpet there's two roaches [__]
each other my mom's in the in the
kitchen making you know bologna and [__]
and I'm like Mom I gotta tell you
something
she's like what
and I'm like you're not gonna like it
and she's like oh my God
did you get someone pregnant and I'm
shooting ghost loads I'm 11. it's like
no and I'm like no and she's like
did you are you in trouble with the
police and I was like no she was like
are you doing drugs I'm like no and
she's like oh my God what's next
are you smoking cigarettes and I'm like
[__] you smoke what the [__] so she's
like yeah and then a week later like and
which she didn't know and I told her
this I was like [__] for like the last
like year as we've been walking to the
bus stop I just you flick your [__] and
I just grab it
yeah and then we would smoke together
anyway so I did that from what a great
scene in a movie or something you're
seeing a young kid walk his mouth she's
not even paying attention to him she's
gonna know where else she flicks a
cigarette he [__] grabs and he just
continues I should put that in something
um yeah so I smoked till I was 25 and
then I quit for three years like a
secondhand son you know second hand
um
and then I quit last year because I then
did the Vapes and you were smoking real
cigarette you got into Vapes huh I got
in a vape so I quit at 25 for three
years and then at 28 I got into Vapes
because of my buddy schwei [__]
[__] and then um and then last year I
went on tour with Wiz Khalifa and I was
like
I can't [__] be smoking I gotta stop
so I did it cold with turkey and bro I
was like sweating bullets yeah and
[__] like jolting out of bed like
jolting out of sleep it was it was crazy
but it's like destroyed my anxiety like
all that nicotine I didn't realize how
much anxiety it was giving me that and
then on top of [__] being hungover
and then so once I just really kicked
back on the on the Alcohol stop the
nicotine and just smoked a hell of a lot
more weight I just feel great I [__]
ran two miles today before I got here
nice dude it's been yeah I did some yoga
before I came today Vibe I need to
stretch but I do think that yeah that
nicotine's so bad bro the hardest thing
I've been having to do is quit vaping
this is why I brought this up was
because we you were talking about if you
get drunk you might want to do an eight
ball or something like that because it's
like ah that those inhibitions kind of
go out and you're like [__] it let's go
that's how I feel bro I was in the
studio last night and I was like man I
kind of want to I kind of want a
cigarette like my friends are smoking
cigarettes and everybody's vaping my
[__] new assistant Jaden he's he's
just like he's vaping he's [__]
vaping and [__] I'm like tired
no no but I'm like I'm like what the
[__] and I stayed strong yeah because I
remember the feeling of like I don't
want to do this anymore like this [__]
sucks you know you just whether it's
cigarettes or vaping and you just do it
and do it and do it and then it's really
just like Ugh like I'm not getting that
hit anymore that thing yeah I'm just
doing it's almost like I'm a [__]
robot or something the saddest thing for
me to think about is when I leave here
today what choice am I going to make am
I going to get in my car and stop at The
Vape Shop they don't even sell the ones
I like anymore so now I'm down to doing
some like third string Vape some [__]
you know it's like it's this Vape would
never start for any team
you know and I'm gonna but am I gonna go
buy that you know and get like muffin
ice or some [__] [__] I'd almost
rather smoke a cigarette yeah because
I'm gonna hit it two times and all I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna feel so bad about
myself how about when the juice is just
like you ever get the juice where it's
like in your mouth and [__] and it's
cool did you ever Jewel no I don't Jewel
oh that was my [__] I used to [__]
just [__] Jewel that [__] yeah this
one's gross no Julie was just [__]
like crack man so good and I'm glad I
cried I never smoke crack well I mean
I'm a crack baby was one of your parents
on crack when you were conceived do you
think uh yeah I told you that they met
at a crack house Theo yeah
that's so cool man I met a girl at a
subway once
but not the same but we both had a
[__] little bit of sandwich in it
since she gave me a beach
you know
um what about uh did you ever see any
crack around the house or no yeah of
course bro yeah my uh one of my my wow
yeah my sister's uh bruh my sister's
boyfriend at the time showed me how to
cook crack in the house
what do you do like how do you make a
good crack I'm gonna be honest bro this
was like 10 years ago it was one time he
just had to [__] on the stove he had the
actual he he had the Coke and he [__]
mixed it with some [__] and some [__]
baking powder and put it on the thing he
was like okay now grab the [__] it
was like in a jar in a mason jar he's
like okay grab that [__] and he like
gave me these like mittens and I put the
mittens on he's like now pour it and do
all this [__] [__] and Meanwhile
we're not wearing masks or anything and
this [__] [__] were a mess you're in
a crack house
this is an MIT bro
yeah
yeah and then it's like billowing
upstairs through the vents where there's
like little children sleeping I'd be up
there sleeping with them yeah not with
them but oh [__] I'd be in a crib up
there for sure dude bro God that's got
to be nice
I uh I never got to smoke crack man I
always wanted to and that crazy
um I always wanted what do you mean you
never got to you this you sound like you
sound like me talking about the Grammys
like I got nominated I went there I
[__] lost to Bruno Mars I never did
it but I like really wanted it yeah what
the [__] what I feel like that one yeah
I would you know you always just imagine
the [__] flame hitting around that
rock and you being on the receiving end
of it it's like Leo in a
[__] Wolf of Wall Street you ever see
that he's like y'all came off this crack
with me he's like I
didn't they do it that's what it's like
bro I've seen my dad I remember one of
my when my dad was 18 and now he's he
claims that since then he hasn't smoked
crack
okay but I know he's definitely had some
good some good years where he's been he
was clean is clean I don't [__] know
whatever I still got to text this
[__] back I got him on reds
[__] man is it weird not to communicate
with him much let's see what he's let's
see the last thing he said is it I mean
yeah you really feel like a connection
to him or do you have to create a
connection with him whoa
this [__] just sent me the
craziest picture
of my that child's family I think so he
just said he sent this to me with no
[__] contacts yeah that's
whoa what the [__] anyway
um oh my God is he a grandfather no I
think that's my [__] dad right there
that really likes game [__]
light skin looking [__] right
there at the top yeah lashed out with
that with the afro let me see that [__]
dang dude that guy looks like a a wolf
on the bottom right he does
wow dude that's crazy let me I'm gonna
text him right now and be like what the
[__] pictures yeah who is this picture
it looks like the Jackson sevens
uh yeah so uh that's crazy dude I wish
half my family was [__] black dog
it's dope it's a Vibe I really love it
yeah because it would seem like man
culture's going on in here yeah
culturally it's really cool man it's
like I I love I love being black I'm
gonna I'm gonna be real and I remember
we go to Black funerals dog god
it was just [__] should be jumping oh
it sucks and it's hard and they have to
worry everybody's turning the [__] up
hugging some big black I don't even
[__] know where Brodus crying into
her tits oh my God wait what black
funeral were you at just when I was
growing up a lot of people would die in
our area and they were black and so we
go to the funerals and uh it was just
sad you know like some kid shot himself
in the head oh that's deep I hope it was
you know I'm assuming closed casket
yeah I'm pretty sure I don't remember I
mean I'm sure it was I didn't I don't
think at that age I went up there but
the other kid this other kid died on the
BET playing basketball
what else
people were dying in our area a decent
amount
um question yeah monkey got bit by a bat
I remember and got some type of
encephalized joke I swear to God A kid
got bit by a bat oh yeah look up a bat
disease what is it what is this kovid
rabies can spread okay what so he died
of rabies bats after mine or something
rabies yeah or whatever they call it how
did he not go get checked oh y'all are
in the hood right well nobody was
getting checked they didn't [__]
you're getting checked then there
weren't yeah people would pray over them
and somebody would you know oh my God
don't get me [__] started on that
[__] my mom she was so like insane
religious like CR like she's so
hypocritical she's like don't you take
the lord's name in vain God damn it
[__] like that's my mom bro
I love your reactions but um yeah no
it's a
it was it was a weird thing to say do
you miss the Anarchy of that kind of
stuff of course not no I'm not [__]
sick you know like sick people miss that
[__] and I was and I had to I had to
break that cycle like bro there's times
when my phone like my phone's in in
another room and I'm just sitting
somewhere and I'm alone like I'm talking
to my wife I'm hanging with my baby I'm
I'm on a call I'm one of this and then
everything stops and I'm like
because I'm and I have to tell myself
I grew up in such chaos
that I find peace boring hmm that's
[__] up like that's deep and I had to
learn that so when I think about like
women I would date and there would be
like drama and you know she's like what
the [__] you don't know me you're like
what do you think all this [__] and I'm
like
yes [__] like I'm so used to that
because my mom like man I remember my
mom through this [__] crazy ass like
it was like a a metal container for pens
and it sliced my stepdad's [__] skull
open and his brains and it was like the
craziest [__] and then she got locked up
and then I was living with him
um but he wouldn't let me leave and it
was like the craziest [__] and then oh
man he had like Desert Eagles he'd be
shooting at the cops and he [__]
would take me on his Harley-Davidson
it's the craziest [__] but between that
and like fights and arguments I mean we
had these [__] weirdos that were like
the Manson family that like stayed with
us and then they ended up killing their
baby and it was just like the wildest
[__] so as I got older you know when I'm
meeting like
hey my name's Samantha my parents are in
law and I'm like [__] you're too boring
for me I need some yeah I need you to
stab me [__] beat me up like you know
what I mean like get a [__] sword out
of your car yeah like that's what I felt
I needed and then I had to break that
cycle and realize like no like that's
just because that's how you grew up but
most people don't realize that he's like
my sister well I won't say which one
she's gonna be mad as [__] I'm talking
to my sister one day and she's like
she's like yeah she's like yeah but I'm
seeing this guy I think he's the one I'm
like oh word for real you know she got
like a bunch of kids all different baby
daddies and I'm like okay
so he's the one she's like yeah he
treats me so good I love him blah blah
blah blah and I'm like that's dope how'd
y'all mean she's like well actually I've
known him since I was like 15. I'm like
damn it sounds like a good dude he's
treating you good she's like yeah I'm
like what does he do she's like what I'm
like what does he do for a living what
does he do oh you know
[__] what speak up what what does he do
she's like oh you know he's just in Life
or prison for murder
i'm like [__] what like for real bro
for real I'm like you wait hold up you
found the one she's like yeah we're
gonna get married he treats me so good
I'm like what the [__] is wrong with you
go to Starbucks man why don't you get
you a good man you know what she says to
me she goes I just love Thug [__] damn
bro and I'm like girl I love you with
all my heart but you gotta figure yes I
figured this [__] out am I right bruh
and I'm like damn that's so deep
and she bought yeah it's crazy I love
her though she's I mean sometimes you
want to love something that can't love
you you know if it's a you know I think
if sometimes thugs no matter what I mean
no matter who they are I wonder if they
have a tough time loving people you know
like I wonder if that's what she means
by that oh yeah but also women will be
like yeah they want a murderer bro I'm
telling you women want to be [__]
murdered dog and any woman that says she
don't man I think she's on she's on
woman I just never understand they love
all the murder shows you know oh look at
Tiffany got hacked up and he'll be
texting their friend uh that [__] you
know like damn bro [__] it all right dog
Tiffany ain't even cold in your [__]
jealous
because her husband [__] worked for
Cutco or whatever oh my God but it's
crazy people would they want that they
want a commitment from man even if it's
[__] yeah but they also want to like
why why [__] be wanting to change a
man can we just talk about that a [__]
wouldn't change a man and she she do it
you know he'd be like he'd be like
whatever and she's like
she could take a [__] and just
change this about him and she's like if
you want to be with me you got to change
this other thing too he's like all right
girl and he's trying to better himself
and she's like are you going to have to
change that too and then a year goes by
he's a [__] brand new man and she's
like it's over he's like what [__]
she's like you changed
yeah yeah am I right yeah
no she's like why you got a top hat on
you're like looking like Mr Peanut yeah
you [__] bought it from me oh man
anyway how did you know when you met
your wife that that was it man was that
hard was that a weird it was definitely
hard you know what I'm saying my [__]
was because you were I'm sure you was
easy to date oh I thought he was talking
about my dick anyway
um I truth be told yeah how did you know
like this is I found my wife
I walked in uh to a store three days
after I got separated from my previous
wife
and I saw this this girl and I thought I
thought she was like 24 or something I
was 28 at the time she was 19. I didn't
know this and uh yeah and we had a she
worked at a smoothie shop oh God I
[__] love that bro and she was
grinding she busting her ass she's in
college she's doing all this other [__]
and um yeah man she was really just
super duper sweet and I went back to the
same smoothie shop every every every day
for two weeks and she wasn't there oh
and I was like writing music about her
like a [__] creep and I was like
right it was just like was so inspired
like I don't know if she was just so
beautiful she was breathtaking so I go
back every day in the morning and in the
night in case which shift I don't know
and then I go and I'm like befriending
like all the oh and there's a bunch of
bad [__] that work there and they all
think I'm coming to see them
yo it's crazy like and I remember the
manager was this gay dude and he was
leaving oh now he trying to smash dude
I bought him some chocolates because he
was leaving oh I'm sure so I was like I
was just like I'm gonna be the nicest
[__] I mean I am a nice guy but
I was I'm gonna be extra so she's
hearing about me and she was and she
everybody thought I was there to see
like a different [__] but like she
didn't know and then if she finally
broke two weeks go by and I was like I'm
giving up I go there one night and she
wasn't there and I was like I gotta take
a piss I go take a piss I walk out and I
go to pay for my [__] and I just hear
hey Bobby and I turn around and it was
this [__] angel
and I was like oh my God this is it and
my heart was just beating out of my
chest like bro like [__] crazy for
real and it's like man I've gone through
a lot man and I just [__] I'm getting
publicly divorced and just all this
crazy [__] and it's just so difficult
and here's this like Angel and so I'm
talking to her
and she's so [__] supervisor on a
what like a uh
smooth like some of a smoothie place to
make delicious advisor yeah [__] no she
was looking bad as [__] had her hair all
parted she wasn't looking stupid oh yeah
and then um she's in [__] leggings
and I was like oh my God I'm talking to
her and then she's just so sweet and
she's just talking to me and I'm telling
her about things I have going on she's
like that's so cool you know sometimes
me and my boyfriend no and I was like
what [__] bro sounds like a piece of
[__] yo literally I was like yo this
[__] sucks man what the [__] you got
a boyfriend but I didn't say it like
that I was like oh I was like no way
that's so tight like what's his name
what's his [__] name [__] you better
tell me his [__] name right now I
can't even hear his name oh I don't know
yeah it's a whole thing so she says this
[__] and then
so then I come back I come back like a
week or no a couple days later and I see
her again and what happened and I I was
just like I just talking to her I was
like telling her about all these cool
new things happening in my life oh yeah
definitely and I was just like man like
we should be friends
and she's like so we are friends no no
she was like yeah for sure and I had
this whole you don't understand like I'm
not joking I like rehearsed for 48 hours
the whole conversation how it was gonna
go how I was gonna get her number oh my
God and then play the long waiting game
because she was worth it you know like I
was like okay I'm gonna we're gonna wait
we're gonna figure this out so
I had this whole thing and I was like we
should be friends and then I start to do
my HBO she's like yeah I could just give
you my number and I was like oh my God I
don't even have to do I didn't have to
do anything so I'm like Okay cool so I
get her number and when do you text her
dude I [__] texted her that night
what I don't give a [__] you're gonna
[__] it up I put my dick on the table
bro I'm not scared of [__] you be you
100 and they're either gonna accept you
and love you for who you are or they're
[__] not they're not and that's what
I'm saying no that's a real I mean
they're not for you maybe I I yeah you
gotta be yourself bro like be you in a
[__] relationship that's why it's so
[__] when two people get together on
a [__] date and they're not they're
lying they're being them like I'll be on
the first day I'll be like damn [__] I
just ripped ass in the bathroom wow I'm
like that's who I am I'm like me and my
wife on our first date I was like I'm
not in in a weird way I was just like do
you want children one day she was like
yeah I was like oh dope do you see
yourself getting married I'm like what's
up you super religious she's like no I
believe in something like an energy or
something Universe I'm like okay I asked
those important questions because most
people don't and then five years [__]
later they get in divorced because they
never talked about them in the first
place yeah so anyway nice [__]
rubbing a gemstone on her vulva
but yeah they get weird like that so
dude so you knew and how long after that
did you get engaged well the crazy thing
is super duper long story short
I created this like fake release party
for a mixtape called Bobby Tarantino 2
that just so happened to be on St
Patrick's Day but it was really
basically The Great Gatsby are you
familiar with the Great Gatsby so I
created this whole party just to invite
this business yeah with all her all her
friends
and then she ends up bringing her
boyfriend no yeah it was crazy so she
brings her boyfriend and the dude comes
in and he's like oh Roger can I have a
picture with you and immediately I was
like Swedish
is that Swedish did I just do Sweden I
think so no students like this yeah or
is that more German I don't think
whatever I'm not good with [__] like
if I do an Irish when I do editors sound
kind of Jamaican at the same time I'm
gonna do Irish man yeah anyway [__]
whatever bro long story short she she
she didn't say with that guy
because what did it take and were you
lucky flirting with her what was
happening um I flirted with her but she
never flirted back wow that was that was
beautiful yeah because I was like [__]
I want to take you on on a private
helicopter to San Diego and [__] at the
party yeah I'm like playing I'm playing
pool
that's gangster yeah I wasn't like yo
you want to go see my [__] redhead
collection oh [__] what you mean
murderer hey [__] you want to go to
private jet what the [__] you're right I
love it all right anyway right you're
right but yeah I was definitely flirting
with her a little bit but I was
respectful I wasn't like [__] this dweeb
did it like it wasn't like right right
and then she just like I I they just
that happened she just saw a man I'm
gonna be real she was dating no she was
dating a boy they [__] went to high
school together and [__] and then she
saw a man I was like what's good and
that's and that's a real thing it's like
whatever eight months later we were
engaged
um she was she got
I knocked her up and like may we were in
Tokyo oh yeah when I when I bought that
uh cultural appropriation kimono and
um and I knocked her up we had a really
bad fight
and then yeah it was like so bad it was
like the worst fight we've ever really
had and then I shut that [__] down I was
like this is [__] stupid we don't
need to be doing this [__] we need to
respect each other and if we feel don't
let animosity build don't this don't
that but I told her the the real thing
is she was pissed off because we're at
some [__] club in Japan everybody's
wasted and um the woman who who led us
through the door I was just like oh this
is a pretty dress because I'm just I'm a
gentleman like if I see a woman and
that's just from being raised around
women like oh nice earrings like and my
wife knows me she gets it like but you
don't think you'd low-key do it for some
sort of a return no never never known
yeah especially with women because for
me women doesn't matter like she could
be bad she could be not what you would
call uh you know a bad [__] like you
know what I mean or whatever just just a
normal looking whatever I don't know
Library yeah let's keep it 100. the
[__] could be ugly or she could be
[__] a supermodel okay and I will be
like oh I love your shoes or I'll be
like oh right yeah I'll be like your hat
yeah your nails are they gel is it gel
is it acrylic right I don't give a [__]
I just like your arms yeah whatever
anyway so she just got mad that as I
said the [__] had a nice dress oh yeah
women will get upset about that and I
was like don't you ever bring that [__]
to me ever [__] again because I was
like I would never [__] do that I
don't give a [__] like this is not
whatever and it was so stupid and then
we argued and I knocked her up yeah
dude if I'm arguing with somebody you
gotta [__] knock them up
that's how most of us got in the world
when you think about that yeah I mean
look at my parents oh yeah they were
hiding on crack and angry and screaming
so you want kids
well they made a good creation man do
you want children I do want some
children you know and I start to get to
the point where it's like yeah I
definitely want to have some children
but also you can't hurry love man you
got you know I like this girl and if it
didn't work out and then I was in this
other relationship and I couldn't commit
and so I just gotta what if you got like
the female equivalent of a sperm donor
what is it I don't [__] know a
surrogate or some chick you could just
knock up and be like here take my sperm
and you just you select because women
they do this they'll select they'll be
like okay he's got to be chocolate six
eight [__] NBA player this that
whatever and you can like pick what you
want and then that woman could have a
child herself so you could do the same
thing you just get like some super bad
gorgeous woman and what do you do drive
you have to do you do sex with them or
do you have to drive over there
definitely not I don't I don't it's a
little more professional than that you
know what I mean you know you're not
that would be like the most expensive
craziest escort of all time it's like
100 Grand I think to do something like
that to do what to get somebody to have
your child that you don't know
really in America yeah well it's like 80
in Mexico I think but you got to go down
there that's going to cost you a couple
G I wouldn't sweat it because like
you're already
you're still you still have like 30
years on when your dad made you so you
got time you know what I mean like you
got it well my my dad was 38 when my
mother was born
yeah but that's it's just it was
different times though not even that it
was different times it's just it's just
like bro who gives a [__] wasn't
somebody they they were upset with Billy
eilish and the guy from the neighborhood
I don't know if you heard about this so
Billy eilish you know she's younger
they're like 12 years difference yeah
but so what she's [__] of age she can
make her own decisions and we don't know
what the [__] we don't we're not in on
their text message that they can be
[__] in love and happy yeah who are
we just saying now I'd be different if
like
she was 17 or you know he was like I
can't wait to knock the socks off that
yeah that'd be a little weird he's like
let me get that kitty Cooter oh no
if he's texting that kind of [__] then
you got to go to jail
um will you guys have any more children
do you think or what do you mean my wife
is currently pregnant with her oh you
got back in there yeah with my second
son what we're gonna name him Leo really
yeah we're gonna name him Leo because my
best friend so here's here's actually
super quick the first thing I ever said
to my wife was nice tattoo and she had a
tattoo here that spelled Noel with two
L's and she says oh it's in my
grandmother's handwriting it's her
middle name and I was like holy [__] and
both sets of her grandparents are in
their high 80s living alone killing it
probably still [__] it's like they're
killing yeah they're amazing and um
so
I actually got hurt mother's name middle
name Grace
um tattooed on me in her grandmother's
name which is really cool but I say this
to say
that since her middle name is her
grandmother's name she wanted her the
second boy's middle name to be her
father's name middle name okay so okay
Kurt David is my father-in-law so our
boy's name will be Leon David Hall but
Leon David is my best friend's name Leon
David rosalom who [__] let me sleep
in his basement when I was homeless
didn't have anywhere to go and almost a
year to the day I signed a Def Jam and
we all moved to LA so I named him after
my best friend Leon David and it's cool
because he's after my best friend who
also has the same middle name as my
father-in-law and yeah we call him Liam
it's a perfect circle Liam Leo Leo is a
good name yeah I like it
um lady killer Leo you know what I mean
yeah it sounds like him he's got to
probably be handsome if you're you I
mean you've seen pretty handsome and
your wife looks attractive that's all I
see him handsome am I handsome or do I
seem handsome I think you seem handsome
as far as I'm gonna go dude yeah I think
your answer has time to get tough yeah
you're a handsome guy and you got great
skin you're handsome thanks dude you got
great skin yeah I'm just getting older
though that's the only thing you know
look at you what is the [__] you talking
about you got great skin you got time
comes and get you look at your hair
look at you what are you talking about
you look good you look great
oh dude I look like a home of stuffed in
a non-homeless guy
um
one thing that's interesting about you I
think you're I think I love what you're
doing man I love the fact that you're
kind of like you're not pivoting for
music but you're adding to your ability
to perform with also people seeing more
of your personality 100 which I think is
interesting you know especially coming
from your own life and all the
experiences you've had I think
some people they only have what their
music is but you there's so much I mean
it's [__] there's a lot to [__]
unpacked there I mean there's so many
sentences you said during this chat that
I could be like what about this what
about this so I think there's going to
be a lot of like um just breadth of like
not only knowledge but just like sharing
of
experiences that you've had or being
able to relate to people it's probably
going to be a big part of your future
you know so I think it's cool man that
people are getting to know you more and
that you're allowing that to happen
because I think um there's probably a
need for that in the world you know
because a lot of people don't have the
experience that you've had
you know yeah man I just I I just uh I
kind of see this as the the second
chapter of my career you know or second
act if you will of my career
and yeah the music is so therapeutic
I'll always do it I love it it's like I
it's so easy for me to do it you know I
was on vacation a couple weeks ago and I
made 37 beats in a day damn on vacation
I woke up I was just in bed and then
played with my son and then put him down
for a nap and finished my 37 for the day
like I don't know I just love it and
it's amazing but this [__] I live on
this because like I used to really be so
jealous of comedians because I'm like
these [__] [__] especially the
greats oh yeah they go out on stage
they're themselves and all they need is
a [__] microphone I gotta go out
there I gotta have [__] lasers and
big screens and kids on Molly in the
back and everyone's like oh my God and
that's why all my when I when I do go
out on tour because I'm definitely torn
for this I'm stripping it down I've been
in arenas for like [__] six years I
don't want to [__] do Arenas I want
to do theaters three to seven thousand
cat [__] theaters simple backdrop the
shittiest lighting show and it's gonna
be about me as a [__] MC doing my
thing but what I'm saying is here this
being me
uh is the best thing I know how to do
and be so even when I do rap there's
still some personification of like yeah
but I'm like Logic the the rapper this
is the side of me that's rapping or the
side of me that's got to be super like
here I can just be I can be me I can be
funny we can talk we can like do I could
literally do this all [__] day right
the fact that's letting me know that
this is where my future is is going
especially on YouTube and social media
and I'm making a serious serious
investment so for all my fans who are
watching let me just tell y'all y'all
I'm spending [__] a [__] ton of money
to do the YouTube and the green screen
videos and the trap and all this other
stuff and and that's cool man I love it
I went to your channel man I watched a
few videos and I liked it I was like oh
I just feel like I'm getting to know him
it's engaging it's different from the
you know his history as a musician and
also I think it's like um
you know when you grow up in a place
with a lot of chaos and a lot of like
trying to kind of trauma which is a
buzzword that people use these days but
when you grow up in that environment you
don't really get a chance to settle down
sometimes till you're you're almost a
late bloomer in some ways in life where
you don't get a chance to kind of you
know it takes a time for things to
settle it's like Michael Jackson imagine
how Justin Bieber must feel it's a real
thing like for kids who never like
really got to have a childhood you know
yeah and had a childhood in front of the
whole world like Bro think about some
[__] that you've done or said that you
wouldn't even want to say publicly like
that would totally get you canceled
because you were just a normal human
being who maybe said a wrong joke or
there's a like as a kid like as kids
like we all say and do dumb [__] I don't
give a [__] who you are we're humans
well there's two black-faced kids dude
exactly but that's what I mean it's like
we've all done something yeah
[Laughter]
people you think 20 years from now
people are like are you little Eddie is
this you like what the [__] I think it's
really funny though how
it's like a whole not bit I almost said
bit we did the bit but it's like a whole
uh thing on blackface but they don't
show the black face oh no like why would
you blur it out it's almost like Asian
porn yeah where you blur it's like
what's the point oh they blow out the
faces yeah yeah I haven't seen that I
mean I guess maybe it's like because
that's somebody's child I don't know but
it's it's just almost like hey here's
here's a here's a write-up on this thing
and then you go because you want to see
it but you can't see it see it how you
gonna see blackface when the face is
blurred well I mean it's like and also
like at least
um
if the kids are gonna do it let them
[__] do it
or is that the right take or not maybe
not so what I'm trying to say is
[__] no one of them was a cop and one of
them construction worker would you mean
one of them what does that mean I'm just
saying one of them
um dude congrats on the new album it
comes out March uh March no February
24th it's called College Park okay yeah
uh it comes out February 24th it's
called College Park
um thanks so much dude yeah I'd love to
chat again sometime yeah for sure I it'd
be cool you know come by every once in a
while yeah and I want to make my rounds
too man any any homies are different
people that you know that you think it'd
be fun to [__] with that tiger belly
have you been on there oh yeah I want to
do it all man so like let me know you
know I want to [__] with whoever I'll
think of some great ones man all right
yo make sure you check out Troy Bond
okay I'm telling you man the kid he's
really special you know it's almost like
when I first [__] met uh Pete
Davidson we used to hang all the time
and I just I was like oh yeah this
dude's out of here really it's that
feeling yeah it just felt like he had
just like a unique energy yeah and he
does and he's so he's I mean like he
says he looks like a Puerto Rican
lesbian like it's hilarious yeah yeah a
lot of people thought he was Brittany
Greiner remember a couple months ago
there was a lot of you bring that up
honestly Pete Davis and Brittany Greiner
dude Brittany Greiner was at the I went
to the golf this past week and I was in
Phoenix Brittany Greiner was there I had
a chance to meet her
and I had to do something for a buddy
dude I would have loved to be like yo
what was what's that like wait this is a
real thing yeah this is happening it's a
doppelganger oh it's totally in that one
right there though yeah a lot of people
thought that was me Davidson when they
traded for Russia or whatever
dude here's a crazy thing that I heard
what from some like um I was at like a
party and they had some Israeli guys
there and they said that they
the reason Brittany Griner got busted or
got she was over there there's like a
Russian Czar or whatever that pays women
to come play basketball topless over
there
and that's what she was doing over there
in the first place because people no one
asked like what was she even doing in
Russia in the first place oh I don't
know if that's true but it was real
interesting but she just got a haircut
almost got to meet her at the golf
tournament
you have a favorite football team I
[__] hate Sports I'm trying to get
into it I just died oh my [__] it man
it's not that I hate it it's just like
I'm just [__] never I mean I love
skateboarding you know what I mean
that's a sport yeah I used to do that
[__] until I was like 20 years old like
really obsessed yeah I'm actually going
to have dinner with Paul Rodriguez
tonight one of the greatest
skateboarders of [__] all time yeah I
just actually I was doing I was doing
this interview with this cat named Vic
Blends yeah dude I see him I follow him
on Tick Tock he's super dope and I did
an interview with him and I won't I
won't I won't give that away but it was
it was really it was really special and
um anyway I ended up meeting Paul
Rodriguez so that's okay dude well it
sounds like you have a lot of new stuff
going on in your life man thanks for
coming in and sharing it with us man
thanks for being so cool and um you know
I'm I'm glad that You're Sober thanks
man yeah and yeah I feel pretty good
about it it's a little bit
yeah I feel like it's the only way I can
do things now kind of what do you mean I
don't know if I was [__] up if I'd be
able to do anything well I mean were you
[__] up I mean look at you no but it's
just always the fear of being that I
don't know if I go out what tomorrow
what I could be like tomorrow I don't
want to risk that I'm not going to be
able to be here with you I love how
honest you are man and that's how I feel
I I honestly obviously I know we should
be wrapping up here but I just want to
say like how long
had you done hard drugs
I think if somebody had something I
would do it so I didn't go around a lot
of people that had it but if somebody
had a little something on it I would do
it you know I met a dude at a laundromat
one time and did some damn LSD dude
which left all my [__] clothes in
there and [__] left what's your
what's your drug of choice probably
cocaine yeah I would say what does it
feel like if I had to guess I would say
cocaine what's it like
let me think I like cocaine because it
makes me feel exactly how I want to
immediately like having a beer it's like
hey I gotta talk to Patrick or Ricky you
know what I'm saying if I have cocaine
dude I get to go home [__] hold on to
my [__] wiener and be scared and wait
what yeah that's what you do dude if
you're doing much cocaine at your house
you hold on to your [__] wiener and
you be scared and then you hope that
you'll live but you don't know if you
will are you [__] serious yeah and
what do you like that feeling do you
like it I think there's a part of me
that relates to that feeling so much oh
yeah but that just sounds like
desperation and all that sounds like
[__] childhood trauma yeah agreed I
think it just it just attaches to that
old [__] I couldn't imagine you on
cocaine so like have you how many times
have you ever been on cocaine while you
were doing the show no no no
I couldn't but I couldn't imagine you're
already so like I'd be so scared you're
super chill like this is what's crazy
it's like you're chill but animated at
the same time and I feel like if you're
on cocaine like
you would explode oh I would be looking
at porn on my phone oh my God
and I'd be pretending I wasn't that'd be
the tough part that I would drive and do
cocaine and be looking at like escort
just was this all just tragic and I
think I didn't like but I think I liked
cocaine because I was like I want to
feel I don't want there to be any
ambiguity about how I want to feel I
want to feel how I want to feel right
now yeah but you're talking about
grabbing your wiener and freaking out
are you serious I mean I'm 100 serious
what do you like about it though the
feeling like what because I'm just
curious like what does it it gave you an
excuse to be a pho it gave you an excuse
to grab your wiener oh shut the [__] up
what are you talking about that's what
I'm telling you man no man you do blow
right that's how I imagine it all right
all right you're [__] you're in the
Hollywood Hills you got six [__] with
you you know what I'm talking about
you're [__] driving in a drop top
Coop and you [__] do of mine and you
[__] feel Invincible that's what I
think cocaine is you're describing it as
like
that does not sound fun
that does not sound [__] fun at all
man
I'm definitely never doing cocaine now
[__] thank you all right good interview
[__] yeah
[Music]
if I must be
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of my life now I can
feel
it in my bones
but it's gonna take